Hutch literally out here every day arguing for why these people
need to be like totally eradicated. He wants total lefty death,
okay? Every single day. And Prime comes out and he's like, "Oh,
you're not Prime, I don't think you're like going for a really
nice coalition here." Meanwhile, Hutch is like anti-communist
which might just be Hitler
without the anti-Semitism, I guess. He like wants these people
in camps. He's he's like leading the round-up squads,
And and then he's like, "You guys aren't being very nice like
to me. I don't really want to work with you guys."
And then we've got Hutch versus Prime Kai on Live and Learn.
It's really Now, this was before the Zohran Mamdani stuff, which
is interesting.
We could we could take a look at this as well. I might
I might go with the Hutch stuff because honestly, I might go
with the Hutch stuff just because
I think it's going to go stale if I don't do it now. I think
this is we're we're approaching like one of the last
that we can actually go and do this, all
I think I think we got to do this one and then we can do the
Airdyne stuff, whether that's Saturday or tomorrow, we'll see.
Hutch is pro-segregation
or sorry, Hutch is pro-segregation here, I heard, versus Prime.
I thought it was the opposite, but I'm not totally sure.
AOC tweeted a clip of Cenk Uygur saying that the majority of
taxes go to war. He is real dumb.
Um that sounds dumb, yeah. And I I don't want to prime you to
grill you too much, Prime, but but I'm a little hesitant of the
the narrative of you know, the powers that be. There are people
that don't want to see Mamdani succeed, but you know, I'm hesitant
of some of his policies, right? Like I'm not sold on rent control,
but I do like a lot of his other stuff. Now, if some of these
things don't work, if he does win, can can we definitively say
that like I I don't want there to be this narrative of like someone
sabotaged him. Like what if like would you attribute any of his
policies to not working because of what they are if they don't
I just want to know. don't work.
Is Soy Boy like slowly becoming IRI? >> on what we're talking
about, right? Like uh Like Soy Boy looks
I know IRI's got like a condition or something with the eyes,
the puffy eyes, but is Soy Boy now becoming is he getting the
same thing? What's happening
Where'd the where'd the puffiness come from? Like uh um there
can be a scenario where I'm saying I would say like, "Okay, we
had a chance, right? He put in the policy that he intended to
put in place, right?" And then it failed spectacularly. Turns
out this doesn't work, right? And yeah, I would lay that on his
feet and I'd say as a leftist people who have supported those
policies, well, we need to go back to the drawing board. Okay.
Prime, when >> Wait, would you though, Prime? Would you
though, just just to be real? IRI with an actual good point here.
It's so easy and there's no way to argue this, so it's like something
you can't say, but it's kind of [__] up. It's like
it's so easy to just in a vacuum say, "Yeah, of course if the
policies failed, I'd agree to that." And then later on down there's
like some failure that happens and they're like, "Well, it wasn't
really the policies, it was something
Uh okay. All right. That's not true. That's not true. I'm not
saying you're lying, I'm just saying that I I'm feeling like
the excuses would be made saying, "Oh, he was undermined by this.
He didn't really get to do what he wanted." I mean, don't you
feel like people will say that on his behalf? Copium is a thing,
yeah. Copium is absolutely a thing, right? But again, it depends,
right? Because I think people on your side, IRI, right? Will
And I'm not not putting Oh, you should have you just should have
called them out. IRI, of course they will. We got people just
like you in the in the you know, socialist version of being a
left a leftist as well, okay? My socialist community, we've got
plenty of IRIs around who will always cope for whatever in any
possible way to still support the exact things they were supporting
yesterday, all right? There's lots of people like you. >> this
on you, right? I'm just saying people on your side of the spectrum
will absolutely do what they can to undermine this person and
make some bad faith arguments, right? And again, not that like
it doesn't happen from other sides as well, right? But this is
just how it how it'll shake out. So yeah, that's that's what
you expected, right? People are going to craft a narrative, right?
That's what we do in politics. We craft a narrative for the for
the general audience to understand, people weren't following
this, right? So that they can have our opinions on these things,
right? Rather than any other opinion, right? So there's going
to be a Why does Prime always have his face like literally in
the camera? Because he wants the appearance that he could headbutt
you at any moment in time, okay? uh money, a lot of grade to
pass whether he's succeeding or not, right? Whether he's actually
passing policies that are work and that are
received well by New Yorkers, right? There is going to be efforts
to craft a narrative to say, "It was all a failure. It was all
a failure. So don't try it again, right? Certainly don't give
him another shot and don't spread this to other cities." Well,
let me let me just say it and pass the mic here. I just want
to say I hope he succeeds. He's got a D next to his name. He's
going to be a Democrat, so I don't want to see any Democrat fail.
So I'm I'm really rooting for him and and you're not going to
hear me criticizing him or trying to say he's bad or One thing
that we I just want to say I I'm not saying that you would be
doing One thing that we've talked a lot about on this podcast
is is like going to be his ability to to deliver on his agenda,
but Prime, do you worry that you're setting a standard that he
just can't possibly meet? I feel like all four of us on the pod
here, we have a pretty realistic sense that, you know, he'll
be able to do some things unilaterally, but he's going to need
the legislature and the governor to do any kind of tax hikes,
so that seems a bit
Apparently, this is the thing Cherry's talking about in chat
right now. Little Bill. Prime Kai looks like this guy. Little
Bill. I have no idea what this is. I've never seen this before.
The resemblance is
kind of uncanny. I'll give it I'll give you that. I don't I I've
never seen it before though, so crazy reference. Crazy >> sketchy,
although she's indicated that she might be open to that kind
of a thing, but he's just walking into this mayorship, what do
we call it? The mayor the mayorship? mayorality or I think it's
mayorship, yeah. With a with a lot of institutional opposition
to his broader agenda. Should should you really hold it against
him if he can't sort of move mountains and deliver 100% of his
legislative agenda or or a policy
No, not necessarily. I'm saying like I'm not feel like it's weird
to say that I'm holding him to this impossible standard. I'm
actually I think I'm being very realistic. I'm understanding
that
he has the entire well, a lot of the institutional weight of
the Democratic Party against him and certainly all the Republican
Party. He has >> personal phone calls from Obama. I mean,
he's you know, I I understand he's divisive, but that's a pretty
pretty powerful show of support right there, all right? >> Oh,
Obama called him. Oh, wonderful.
Yeah, I didn't I didn't I DIDN'T SAY
THAT'S THAT'S DEMOCRATIC ROYALTY. THAT'S DEMOCRATIC ROYALTY.
All right, so first of all, I don't and maybe I I my information
is old because I haven't been following the race like every every
now and both, but um did Obama Did Did Prime just throw like
some shade at Obama? endorse him? Has he campaigned for I don't
I didn't hear that actually, no. No, not endorse him, but he
he called him then, right? He took up part of his valuable time.
Oh, that's wonderful. All right, I guess it would be great.
just be like it's not that big a deal. He didn't endorse him.
He didn't campaign for him. He didn't do [__] He
called him once. Let him Let Zohran say, "Oh, me and Obama talked."
It's not that big a deal. >> No, but that's a side stopping
short of an endorsement. I I I think what Hutch's point and I
I think that you're you know that, right? Like yes, and I think
it's weaker. I think that he should endorse >> I don't
care. I don't care that he don't care. Right? No, I don't care.
Like I actually This is a Democratic socialist throwing his weight
behind him. That'd be one thing, right? To be like put his weight
behind him, but he's not actually doing that. You're saying he
had a conversation. Great.
What what am I supposed to do, right? I'm supposed to go It was
a
It was a private conversation where Obama relayed that he was
he found Mamdani's campaign to be inspiring. It's not an explicit
public endorsement, but you know, that's not nothing. And I feel
I feel like I feel like Just real quick, let me I feel like Hold
on, let me let me Hutch finish real quick. I feel like someone
in your position should not be so like allergic to that kind
of power. You know what I mean? Like you're you're kind of like
pushing that away.
I mean,
you're you're taking this like actively hostile kind of position
when it comes to Hochul and Obama, but this is you know, this
is a guy that's a Democratic socialist poised to become the mayor
of the most populous city in the country. And so and he's getting
support from these like unlikely figures and you're like He's
not supporting Well,
but you're you're Wait, Prime Prime, I think the the idea is
yes, Obama didn't come out and be like, "I'm fully behind Mamdani,"
which is would be ideal, obviously, from that person in power,
but for most mayoral races, if not all of them, Obama is not
involved whatsoever. And by putting his name next to it, I'm
going
Well, I just think that it's it's the very least above a positive
or above a neutral, excuse me, which is positive because you
now have headlines of Obama attached to Mamdani. It's not as
far as you'd like it to go, but it is helpful. I I think to it.
Yes, just like Obamacare, right? I mean, it's something, right?
Not as far as you'd like it to go, apparently useful, but like
I mean, it's something, right? I I just Is Prime trying to be
like unlikable by everybody? It's actually kind of funny. He
might he might even be right sometimes, but he's just like he
comes in and he attacks like the most popular Democrat that exists
for like not being able to go I don't
I don't know what the goal is here. He called, right? And and
so I I guess
should sing his praises. Look, Obama, who has spent his time,
right? Outside of office doing Netflix documentaries, right?
Like pretending to be above it all as the country burned around
him, right? He finally decided to step out and talk to someone.
I feel like um What am I expected to do with this? He's not good
enough at it. I feel like people with your attitude If he's trying
to do lefty Trump, he's not good enough at it. He is not good
enough. It's just soy. It's like soy, it's not commanding, it's
just soy. Dude, lend credence to the idea that the establishment
should pivot to the center instead of trying to work with you
guys. Okay, that's Whatever. Yes, I don't get I don't get it.
Exactly, you're not exactly incentivizing like a friendly coalition,
are you? I don't I don't care. >> What are you What's your
goal? I don't
Hutch literally out here every day arguing for why these people
need to be like totally eradicated. He wants total lefty death,
okay? Every single day. And Prime Prime comes on and he's like,
"Oh, you're not Prime, I don't think you're like going for a
really nice coalition here." Meanwhile, Hutch is like anti-communist
which might just be uh without the anti-Semitism, I guess. He
like wants these people in camps. He's He's like leading the
round-up squads, okay?
And
and then he's like, "You guys aren't being very nice like to
me. I don't really want to work with you guys."
Oh Oh, hold on. My goal is to uh increase human flourishing,
right? And I think to do that would require um uh That's a joke,
by the way. I don't think Hutch is actually like okay. Hutch,
you're not actually It's just a joke. >> uh left leftist
positions. Um But it would require power, right? Uh it certainly
does require power. Um but that doesn't require It certainly
doesn't require groveling. Do you Does Hutch is so Hutch is so
silly.
Um you you need certain voting blocks. You could just say we
don't want this voting block. You could say I don't want this
voting block ever. They're too hard to please.
But you can't say, "Oh, well, you guys don't have power." It's
like, "Yeah, they don't have power." is exactly why they're saying,
"Well, we're not going to vote for you because you. You never
incorporate us. You don't give us You're You're like the only
coalition we side with and you sit here going, "Uh maybe if you
guys Maybe you guys just agreed on with us, you'd have some power."
It's like, "No, we give you our vote so you like come to our
come in our
We don't We don't sit here to be lectured by you about how we're
hurting you. We We want certain things and if you're not going
to give us those things, you. And
that's that's just how it is. Yeah, we're we're going to hurt
both of us.
But you're the people who actually have a shot at power. We have
a shot at nothing. We want a tiny little drip and you guys don't
want to give us anything,
Um it certainly doesn't require um suddenly getting amnesia.
It doesn't require getting amnesia about like the past 20 years,
right? Um like miss like misremembering the Obama years and misremembering
his post-presidency
and all of a sudden being ecstatic that he gave a phone call.
>> But the asking you to be like No one's asking you to
be like, "Oh, you're asking me No one's asking you to be like,
"Oh, you're asking me to be like Thank you. Thank you, God King
Obama for, you know, taking 10 minutes out of your day." It's
more of just like acknowledging like, "Oh, this is good for Mondani.
He's getting, you know, former presidential recognition. This
will catapult him into a higher tier." It's not like, you know,
the difference between winning or losing. And the endorsement
would obviously be more
No one's asking you to say, "Thank you to Obama." It's just This
is a good >> Well, then okay, fine. Then I can give you
this. If that's all you're asking, right? Well, here's what I'll
do. By the way, I should say Prime does seem to be arguing is
more of a
Like he's not looking for compromise really either. Like the
compromise stuff, he's like literally [__] on the
things that were compromised in a positive direction for like
the socialist part of the party. I don't know what he's going
for in this case either, right? Why the [__] wouldn't
Obama call the Dem primary winner? Um
Yeah, and I think Obama It's one of those things where it's like,
"I'm going to call this person. I'm not going to endorse. I'm
going to call them. They can talk about the call." It's like
a pseudo-endorsement of some sort. And then I'm also in with
them. They don't think I just totally like snubbed them.
Yeah, it's it's totally normal for him to call. Right. Um as
you I think Soy said previously or maybe it was Pisco. Um like
whether this is, you know, on the scale of bad, neutral, or positive,
right? It's slightly past neutral into positive. Hooray. I thank
you for more crumbs, President Obama. I I want to get to something
I mean kind of a little bit halfway, which is there have been
legitimate criticisms, I think, of Obama's post-electoral victory
behavior, including him dropping off the
after his first election win and not really doing anything with
the the grassroots coalitions that he had built from an electoral
perspective.
>> He He dismantled Obama for America, right? That's what
happened. And then also in Trump's first term being conspicuously
quiet. I know that that was like a norm or whatever that other
presidents did somewhat. I mean, I don't even think it was a
fully consistent norm. There were other former presidents that
were incredibly vocal in American history. And so And by the
way, this is not just a lefty critique. People like our favorite
person to talk about as our client have said similar things on
on the on their show about, you know, Obama and that coalition
dropping the ball and and and maybe not being in sync with some
of the the rest of the the famously not in sync with Biden himself,
not in sync with Kamala Harris,
and seemingly having his own view of how the party should go,
but also like not intruding. Um so folks, what do you think about
Obama? Do you think there's anything to Prime's critique here?
At least from a non-leftist perspective.
Well, I mean, when you compare him to I don't even think this
is a leftist critique. I think that's like the Democrat critique,
is it not? Is that not just a broad Democrat critique of Obama?
Like, "Hey, you you You bought this entire party. You had control
of all of it. And then kind of like you hollowed it out. There
was no funding left. And when you just walked away, nobody else
was there to pick up the mantle. Nobody was there to pick up
what you had and like carried it forward into the future." Previous
presidents of decade decades prior, he's certainly broken precedent
with um how much he's been like vocal. You could argue that he
could have done more in the era of Trump and might agree with
you, but he's definitely much more present when it comes to like
stumping for Democrats than you saw from previous presidents.
Well, you you would want him to be more active. One, because
he's a great speaker. And two, because Trump was being as as
active as humanly possible in every possible direction, right?
Trump was constantly on his bully pulpit. Even when he any Even
when he was president, he was still on his bully pulpit commenting
on everything. And so it's like, "Well, we got a guy kind of
like Trump who's a huge presence on our side who is just sitting
out right now. Who's just AFK." Like literally our guy, the only
guy that's remotely comparable to Trump in terms of the influence
throughout the party, the only guy who's remotely comparable
is sitting out. Why?
Yeah. It's like how many how many uh candidates like George W.
Bush stumped for after he kind of like >> Yeah, Jeb Jeb.
Same with like H.W. Bush, Carter, you know, like even Reagan.
Like I don't know how alive he stayed. When did he die? In the
'90s? He died in uh 2005, I think, right? >> but by the
time of his second term, he was already kind of like, you know,
having the the wormtongue wife, you know, astrologying her way
through >> No, the astrology thing is true. That's true,
but the the dementia stuff happened, I think, later after his
term. But yes, the the astrology wife thing is absolutely true.
I just, you know, like I want a I want a Democratic Party that
is strong enough to take on the Republican Party right now. And
I would love nothing more than to have this party be like a big
tent that would allow for people like you, Prime, and also people
like IRI. But the way that you speak, it doesn't seem like you're
interested in the same thing. You want a more homogeneous Why
is he lying? He's literally just lying. He's He's just
He spends all of his time trying to cut people off, trying to
purity test people out of the Democratic Party. That's what he
spends most of his time doing.
I would just feel weird. Like I wouldn't you just call this out?
Like, "Hey, you're like literally infamous right now for spending
all of your time on this. You call it your project."
Why are you saying you want it to be a bigger of tent for all
of us? That's not what you want. You You Your goal is literally
to have the tent end at a very specific, calculated point so
that a lot of leftists are cut out of it. Which is totally fine.
You can argue for that, but don't lie to my face.
You're just
I need to hit the desk, but I don't have the sound effects. Kind
of Are you trying to take over the Democratic Party or like what?
Well, I'm certainly trying to take over the Democratic Party.
I want more of the power to be in the leftists' hands than in
the corporate Democrats' hands. However, it doesn't mean that
like >> What does Hutch mean by that? Wait, what did he
just say? >> Prime and also people like IRI. I would love
nothing more than to have this party be like a big tent that
would allow for people like you, Prime, and also people like
IRI. But the way that you speak, it doesn't seem like you're
interested in the same thing. You want a more homogeneous kind
of Are you trying to take over the Democratic Party or like what?
Well, I'm certainly trying to take over the Democratic Party.
I want more of the power to be in the leftists' hands than in
the corporate Democrats' hands. However, it doesn't mean that
like I would throw IRI out, right? IRI >> I mean, first
of all, like look at him. I don't get the wall? He's No, he doesn't
get the wall. Look at IRI, right? Like uh You have plenty of
reading material on your way back. that, right? No, IRI gets
Hutch will say anything he thinks will give him a one-up optically
in the conversation. Well, it's just weird cuz I don't watch
enough of this, right? But I can track this is just an obvious
lie. And I don't I don't know why these guys are letting him
do it. Why are you just letting him gaslight Prime Kai?
Like, "Hey, Hutch, you've literally been on here. You've been
on a soapbox for months now talking about how people like Prime
can't be in your party. How you think they're they're all antithetical
to your party." And so when you say to him, "Well, I actually
would really love for my party to include you." It's like, "Yeah."
Well, all you're saying is I would really love for you to believe
exactly what I believe. That's all you're saying. And that's
not a useful thing to say at all.
say, right? And like I don't I don't demand that everyone agrees
with me. I love that people disagree with me. Like that's fantastic.
I love this conversation. I love arguing with my friend my friend
Pisco here. It's so enjoyable. But no, but I think that adds
to the point, right? I think And I I mean this so deeply, right?
I am grateful to my right-wing friends, right? And my my liberal
friends, right? for arguing against me. I I've seen in spaces
where I see spaces left spaces where they like close to themselves
and just talk to themselves and they just come up with ideas.
He knows no one on Livin' Learn is going to call him out. Not
for Prime, okay? Prime's annoying. Maybe Maybe if he was gaslighting
um Kyle Kulinski, okay? If it was for If it was Kyle If it was
Kyle Kulinski here who Hutch was just saying, "I would love for
to be in a party with you." I think all of the rest of them would
would know. They'd feel Kyle's aura. And they'd be like, "Hey,
wait. No.
You don't like Kyle. What are you saying, Hutch?" they were never
tested, right? A lot of nonsense comes out of that, right? I
appreciate testing my ideas, my arguments, all of that against
you all, right? And then I adjust, you know, and I I try to get
better. I try to grow. And I hope the the same thing for you.
I hope you adjust when we have these conversations debates um
so we can all sharpen ourselves, right? Um so yes, I deeply I
deeply want I sincerely want So, I understand most people won't
really listen and absorb what Prime is saying, but he's saying,
"I like that other people are willing to challenge my ideas.
I do want like a takeover of this party, but I want it on the
basis of ideas. I want my ideas to win. I don't want to just
like force people out. I don't just want to like do anything.
I like having conversation. I like having like the the interchange
of ideas. I think this is a good method." So, like that's kind
of important, right? He's saying, "I want to argue with you.
I want you to I want you to think my ideas are good. I want my
ideas to be put into practice and to be tested so that we can
implement them."
Yeah, it's good. All right, I just know a lot of you guys probably
aren't necessarily listening to him, all right.
>> want um um ideological
diversity. However, we're talking about power. We're you're talking
about like who has power in the Democratic Party. You know, I
want the power. But the thing is like the substance of Hutch's
question, I think relates to like look at the election right
now. You have very different Democrats running in different places.
Uh Spanberger in Virginia much more like standard road Democrat,
uh moderate on on several issues, uh
Hold on. Hold on. I've heard I've heard tell of somebody like
this. I've heard tell of somebody like this who does things like
this. Okay, in case you're not watching the stream, apparently
over boy six in chat says apparently there's some obnoxious app
with a red emoji that kept chirping during this episode that
really put Hutch off. critical of Mondani in your habits. You
know, you have Gavin Newsom a kind of I don't know a hybrid in
terms of like very left-wing policies, but also more practical.
And you have Mondani and I think the essence of what Hutch's
question is getting at is he genuinely is willing to accept in
good faith and be like, "Oh great, Mondani won." Are you going
to be happy if Abigail Spanberger wins in Virginia? Are you going
to be happy if like I don't know, let's say Josh Shapiro wins
in Pennsylvania? Or if you know, if if Gavin Newsom runs for
re-election or something in California, would you be happy that
they win in the spirit that Hutch is I think genuinely happy
that Mondani would win. I vote for corporate Democrats all the
time. Like I've That's all my choices have been growing up, right?
I'm voting for a corporate Democrat. I have a corporate Democrat
like a House Representative in in my district, right? Total backbencher,
does nothing. If I told you their name, you'd have to these political
junkies would have to look them up. They have no idea who this
person is, right? But yeah. That's not true. There's no Look,
okay, I was going to say it and he knows he knows, all right?
If there's one thing that I'll never ever impugn Iry's honor
on, it's knowing every single House Representative. This guy
watches C-SPAN all the time. He's like, "I don't think so, buddy.
You think I don't know? You think that I don't know who this
backbencher is? I know all the
Go ahead. Go ahead. Yeah.
This is like press X to doubt moment right here, right? Press
X to doubt. Yeah, I don't think so, buddy. I I'll vote for him
again. Um I I I voted for someone else in the primary against
him previously cuz they were super
But they they got crushed, which was expected. But like yeah,
I'll vote for that corporate Democrat. Like and and I can understand
that again, we need uh people of all types for different areas
of the country,
I can understand that my ideas don't necessarily resonate everywhere
and so we should be putting people in front of them in front
of those audiences who have a better chance, right? But that
also doesn't mean that we necessarily have to accept everything.
Um that we should have some level of standards. And I think my
standards might be different from your standards, but we can
argue about that later. No, it's not about standards. It's about
like the tone. You know, it's just a very you're talking about
you're talking about
Could you say all of that, but like in a way that makes me feel
really safe and comfortable? Cuz like the way you said it made
it feel like I was under attack. Uh like you talked about corporate
Democrats. Could you think of like really cool, but like financially
focused Democrats maybe? Would that would be better. That would
make me feel more comfortable.
No, but I'm but but you know, you're talking about like Hochul
like coming in there and bending the knee. You know, >> Absolutely.
That's just an interesting way to phrase that, don't you think?
I mean, I feel like Yeah, it's it's a fun way, a colorful way
of engaging with
If a centrist talked to you that way, if Hutch talked to you
that way, if it were the if it rolls in reverse like, "Yeah,
Bernie's Hutch does talk to these people that way.
No, but like the thing is if if after the the primary, you would
caught Hutch saying something like, "Yeah, you Bernie bros. Now
bend the knee to Biden." or something. Cuz by the way, some people
did say this.
I understand, but you didn't take it in a positive way. That
wasn't that wasn't
Wait, there's a big difference as well between being the the
group, the coalition that's totally out of power, right? And
and versus like the people who are winning and and saying it
to the people who are losing, right? So, if the losers are saying
it to the winners, that's one thing cuz honestly the winners
have all the power. Like that's just natural, right?
I feel like that's natural.
If black people are telling you, okay, we really want a black
presidential candidate for the first time ever. And and they,
you know, they win eventually and they're like, "You guys need
to get behind Obama. It's really important." That rings a little
different than when you run Kamala Harris you say, "Never bring
us a black black candidate ever again." right? It's like a smaller
block of voters, "Never bring us a black female candidate ever
again."
It's there's just a different tone that comes across both ways,
right? When you when you do like a similar thing there, bend
the knee to this person. It just feels a little different. I'm
not saying that you always have to include the power dynamic
there. I'm just saying sometimes the power dynamic does inform
how that sounds.
Or you all be taking a positive way. Take it in a negative way.
Go ahead. Don't care. I'm trying to make an apology. I'm expressing
myself. I keep getting cut off. To be To be fair, you cut him
off, too. But go ahead. He cut me off when I was talking.
I feel like I feel like the tone I feel like the tone is is kind
of like it's wildly out of step with the reality. Like the reality
is is you got this guy and it's true. He is he is a an exciting
candidate and I've been a great admirer of his campaign and the
way that he's just evolved. And I look at him and I get excited,
but you know, this is Why? Honestly, I think
I I would have to go and like really follow the New York City
mayoral race. Hot take, okay? I think a lot of Zoran's is just
astroturf. I don't I don't think there's actually that much of
a really popular, really cool guy there. Just from listening
to him, I'm like, "Oh, he's like kind of average." Like
Zora Mondani, Cory Booker, I see not a lot of I don't see a ton
of daylight in terms of the personality.
I There, I said it, okay? I realize that's an incredibly hot
take. People are going to hate that. I think he's sort of I think
he's he represents something and people are hyped by the thing
he represents. They're not hyped by the guy. I don't think they're
hyped by the guy at all.
And I think Hutch could have a way to he could have a leg to
stand on here, right? He could have a leg to stand on,
but he he doesn't he just wants to agree with everybody on this.
I don't know why.
I said Cory Booker. I just feel like there's something there
essence-wise that matches up, okay? I just don't see I don't
see Zora Mondani as some kind of special. I watched Obama speak
for the first time and I it was obvious immediate. It was immediate
and obvious,
It's not the same with Zoran. No, we've been saying this about
Zoran. Every time I see him speak, Pan Rider, it's the same thing.
I'm like, "Dude, this guy actually sounds kind of to me." I'm
actually not I'm not inspired at all listening to him. He sounds
boring. He sounds like weird I It's just not there. I think people
are behind the movement
way more than Zoran himself. Zoran is such a strong name. Not
everyone Everyone's thing needs to be a personality. That name
carries, okay? He does have a name. Dude, the shirts the shirts
look cool. The branding was very cool. The branding was
The guy with like 50 You're a right-winger. I'm not a right-winger.
I would literally be a Democrat voter in the United States. Like
down ballot Democrat voter easily. You can call me a right-winger.
I'm not a right-winger at all. 5% of the New York City voter
base are going to probably choose him in the upcoming election
and it feels like you're doing the thing that I see Well, sorry,
but you have to understand
people are people are soft making that comparison a lot, Porter
Beller. There's there's a lot being hoisted or or foisted foisted
on Mondani. There's a lot that's being put on Mondani's shoulders
that he's not ready to carry. I'm telling you he's not ready.
He's not that guy.
But it's fine. see a lot of lefties doing, which is you're treating
Mondani as though he's this like herald of a political revolution.
And the reality is it's like he's, you know, got kind of like
middling popularity for a New York City mayor. And someone like
Hochul is in a much stronger position than he is, quite frankly.
>> Well, wait, Prime, before you respond. Hutch, I got
to turn the question around that I already asked Prime, which
is if Mondani gets in office and everything goes really [__]
well. Every single policy is just like, "Wow, like all the things
that progressives been calling for." then would you kind of start
to shift over of, "Oh, maybe we should move more towards to like
a populist progressive for not every Democrat, obviously, but
more of the more of the already on the left wing should push
a little harder Democrats. It's a case-by-case. Just like what
Prime said. I don't know if he applied it in the same way, but
it's a case-by-case. So, if there's a progressive that's thriving
in, you know, another like D plus 30 city or whatever or D plus
30 district, then yeah, sure, of course. Like I'm not I'm not
picky. That's the point. I'm not ideologically picky right now.
I'm I don't think that really matters right now, to be honest
with you. Policy discussions and ideology take a backseat for
me right now in the era of MAGA to just beating Republicans.
Laugh, but look at Trump 2.0. I again,
the stream content does not appear to You could say that's what
you want, but that's not what you focus on. And I think that's
difficult for people to understand, right? So, you could say,
"Well, it's actually most important to like I'll give you a a
comparison. It's like it's actually most important to me that
um that like I don't know, the laws are upheld or something.
But I don't talk about the legal system all the time, right?
Like technically the most important thing to me is that somebody
can't come into my house and house and shoot me with a gun. But
I don't talk about the laws all the time.
So, he could say something like that. Like that his focus is
politics. He thinks the most important thing in politics is for
Republicans to lose, but he's got a different thing that he does
content on. You can have that opinion.
I don't know. I think if you then are like a pseudo journalist,
you're like an independent journalist in that field that covers
that field and you don't talk about the most important things.
That then rings kind of weird or hollow. So, I don't know. I
can go back and forth on that. I know, bro. I know the threat
of Trump, right? And so we should have no standards, I guess,
right? Policy doesn't matter. It doesn't matter WHAT WE VOTE
FOR.
THE BEST part about him lying about his opinions is now Prime
is going to start giving Hutch lines back to him and Hutch is
now really today.
Hutch lied about his position and now Prime is saying things
that Hutch has said to other people verbatim and Hutch has to
sit here and pretend that he doesn't agree with them and he now
now he's really lost. He's really Oh, I guess because Trump's
here, we just shouldn't have a standard then. I guess we should
shouldn't care.
Oh, boy. Unlucky. Unlucky.
Because I remember if I'm not mistaken, I believe Hutch said,
"Oh, I think like the the pendulum's going to swing back and
we can focus on, you know, cleaning house right now and making
sure we're set and I think things are going to swing back and
we're going to be fine with the Trump thing." Is that not a Hutch
opinion or am I talking about somebody else? I swear to God I've
heard him say that exact thing. Like we're going to see the pendulum
swing back. We can focus on cleaning house right now and it's
going to be okay. Like Trump is a huge problem, but he is actually
ruining himself. He's burning himself alive right now and we're
going to see the pendulum swing back. Is that a Hutch position
or am I making that up? I I I didn't Okay, so I don't want to
say I don't want to be bad faith. I'm actually I'm not trying
to be bad faith. I'm trying to engage with you here, okay, right?
So maybe I misunderstood you. But >> Okay, well, a whole
bunch of people in this chat are literally saying Hutch is Well,
sorry. One guy in the chat is saying Hutch is lying. just told
me was that policy doesn't matter in this age, right? It's just
about beating Trump, right? And what what that sounds like to
me is that it doesn't matter. And you can correct me correct
me in just a second, right? But what it sounds like to me is
that saying, "Well, as long as they have a D in front of their
name, right? Well, that's good enough. Let's replace them as
many Rs with Ds and makes no difference of what they bring to
the table." It's up to the individual voters of each state and
district that choose their primary winner. That's the point.
So if like if the voters in a conservative district choose a
more moderate candidate, great. I'm on board. And if they stand
a better chance to beat a Republican in that district, awesome.
Great. And if the same thing goes for progressives. Like that's
that's where I'm at with things. I'm talking about like an actual
coalition instead of what you're talking about, which is just
this kind of delusional fantasy that there's going to be this
leftist takeover of the party and it's not really like based
on anything right
Does Has Hutch ever heard Has Hutch never heard of like an advocate
or
like like an advocate or
an activist?
Like, yeah, he has a thing. You can have a coalition with activists
in it. You can. In fact, I would say most effective coalitions
do have advocates and activists because they need to actually
be the best representative of their ideas. If you've got a super
socialist who never ever takes a position that any socialist
value, any democratic socialist values important, then they're
not a democratic socialist.
Having an advocate or or
activist in that position can be
worth my mouth like this entire time, right? I haven't said anything
Like sorry, from the exact point of view that from Hutch's perspective,
you'd have to argue that Joe Manchin was an act advocate for
the people of West Virginia, right? He was I realize that probably
people off, but the reason they voted for him was because they
trusted him and he was going to have their interest at heart.
and so he's saying like, "Well, I want a coalition. I want us
all to work together. I don't want you people like you who just
want to take across take over the party. I don't want people
like you who are always going to advocate for this and be against
anything else we do." It's like that's you're going to have all
those people. That's that's literally who Joe Manchin was. about
that that some sort of leftist revolution was about to happen,
right? I just said, "Hey, like we got one person in and I'm nervous
about it because when you're actually given a chance to govern,
then you can be held accountable for it." That's all I've said
so far. I'm not saying anything else, right? Um, uh and so this
is what I'm trying to understand you, right? And what you actually
mean. So like it doesn't um if we have Hold on. Very Wait, wait,
wait. I shouldn't pause yet. Let me back this up. Very important
addition coming to the channel. when you're actually given a
chance to govern, then you can be held accountable for it. That's
all I've said so far. I'm not saying anything else, right? Um,
but uh and so this is what I'm trying to understand you, right?
And what you actually mean. So like it doesn't
uh if we have a coalition simple just a talking about like the
Senate just for just narrow it down a bit. Um, uh we have like
a a Okay, now since we have a lot of, you know, fibbing going
on here, we've added a new emoji, new emote right now, okay?
New emote. Let's see here. A lot of fibbing going on. Stop the
stop the hey gay. Think Hutch be capping right now? 51-49 advantage
in the
Um, but like we have another Manchin, another Cinema, and maybe
others as well who like
sabotage the Democrats, right? In the most crucial of moments
to the point that they like these things were reverberating to
the future because like we didn't get crucial
through and weren't actually able to deliver on our promises
while being in power, right? You'd say that's fine, right? Because
at least we have a D.
It's it's a Democratic Senate rather than a Republican Senate.
You understand that Biden was legislatively like the most accomplished
president basically of the modern era, right? And he did that
specifically because Manchin was serving West Virginia. I mean,
I think like the question would be like do you do you envision
a progressive challenger coming in and and actually making the
kind of like winning the kind of election that that Manchin did?
Could you replace him with a progressive? Is my point. My question.
I I I literally already acknowledged a previously that you that
you couldn't. We should have people in place who can
speak I would it would depend, right? Why don't I don't know
why don't um
Why is there no such thing as politicians who go
"I'm pro-choice,
but I commit to you as the people of West Virginia that I will
run on a pro-life position. I will vote on a pro-life position.
I that is my commitment to you, right? Like I Why that seems
to have totally gone by the wayside, right? Like why can't you
just say, "This isn't my position, but I know I'm representing
you, a different kind of people."
Why why can't they just say, "Hey, I'm not going to I'm not going
to do that." I I understand that the the position here in this
state, in this district is very staunchly pro-life. For example,
I don't even know if West Virginia's a good example here. West
Virginia could be pro-life for all I know. It could be some weird
mix, right? Sorry, pro-choice for all I know. But why can't they
just do that?
Why can't they say like I I will go and I will protect this thing
that's very important to you, my constituents, but I will be
a Democrat in a lot of other senses. That's just
It's absolutely not. I don't I literally
Presumption is all politicians are liars? Yeah, but that's an
easily trackable lie. That's a lie you can hold That's a lie
you can someone with,
Like like their their political career can just end. I'm making
a solemn vow to you as my constituents that I'm going to vote
this way.
As your career is over the second you violate that, right?
If only politicians would be that transparent. If only.
to those audiences best we can. However, I say we have to actually
have to have standards. No, I wouldn't say Manchin's I was a
good idea because Manchin actively sabotage the Democrats in
>> Well, he he voted for Biden's agenda and his judges
the overwhelming majority of the time. But like you you understand
that without a majority you can't get any judges or legislation
right? >> Oh, yes, I understand it. Don't worry. You don't
have to condescend to me. I get it. Yeah. >> The way you
talk makes me question that because you're saying it was a bad
thing that he was serving that, right? Let me just interrupt
quick pause. Simmer down, Hutch. I do feel that a lot of the
things being levied at Prime right now are 90%
dumber progressives that I've seen on Twitter. I I haven't heard
Prime say these things yet. So I feel Wait, no, hang on. He just
said that it was a bad thing that Manchin was serving in West
Virginia. I think what he's saying is that people like Manchin
can sabotage He said he sabotaged >> an otherwise better
agenda, which is true and why Trump was someone who thanked Manchin
for a lot of what he did, even though Manchin was instrumental
in getting a lot of Biden's stuff passed as well. We would prefer
to have someone better. If he's the best we can get, sure, that's
great. We don't want a Republican But you're but you're glossing
over that. Like if if he's the best we can get, then we should
welcome that, right? Welcome it, sure, but not be like He disagrees.
Prime disagrees. That's my
He doesn't want to welcome that, right?
So um I Okay, it depends on what you mean by welcome. I'm not
trying to dodge the question, I promise you. I'm like I'm just
trying to work out what we're >> the shouldn't the question
be what if there was a Democrat in West Virginia who could be
very much like Joe Manchin, but that you had, I guess, like more
overlap with, somebody that could run in the same way like you
don't need a progressive there, but what if there is somebody
else who could have been running there?
Shouldn't that be the question? Like what are you Shouldn't you
have like a good idea of what your like what your negotiables
are, what your non-negotiables are?
But I I actually don't even think Joe Manchin was necessarily
like violating any non-negotiable
tenants of the Democratic Party. He just kind of wasn't voting
along with spending.
I don't know. thing here.
like if like
I wouldn't take away his Senate seat, right? Like, "Hey, like
you've come in like the people voted you in, right?" Um, and
I wouldn't say like, "Okay, now the because he don't he doesn't
agree with my ideology, the Senate should like somehow toss him
out, right?" I'm not saying anything like that. But like what
we what the conversation started was that you specifically said
in terms of your view of well like coalitions like the the the
the coalition in the in the larger battle, right? That it doesn't
matter at all who who comes in, right? So like I'll turn the
question I'll turn it Uh he should never he The the fact that
he was able to recover from that politically, he should have
been destroyed if that's what he was responsible for.
Man, public options, publicly owned stuff, especially in in things
like
that that actually your country over. I don't understand why
nobody else runs on a public option at this point. I feel like
you should be able to pull over some Republicans at this point
for a public option, but back when you're right. Like if instead
we had a the whole list of Democrats who won who were like pro-segregationists.
You'd say like well I I'd welcome them within the party. Right?
They have a D in front of their name not an R. And so thank you
like please let's fill up with pro-segregationists. You're welcome
here. I mean we'd be going back to the Democratic Party of you
know five or six decades ago, right?
Sorry, that didn't answer my question. Would you welcome them
in >> yes. Yeah in that context that wouldn't you rather
have the New Deal and the Great Society? You could never name
this random House member. You could never name this random backbench
Democratic House member, okay? Ever.
I don't know about that. I don't I don't know about that.
Something not Sorry, one second. I'll come to that in a second.
Stop trying to dodge the question and Wait wait wait isn't the
answer I'm not No hold on. No it's not we're not time traveling
cuz you now he's like oh now we're going back in time. No we're
not doing that. I'm saying hey like for 2025
right or 20 into 2026 we have new brand new pro-segregationists
coming into Democratic Party. Would you welcome them because
they have a D in front of their name instead of R? He says no.
Uh-oh.
People are like oh this is by the way there's no difference.
There's absolutely no difference. If you say no to this and yes
to the the pro-life people the pro-life Democrats
it's just you're you're getting rid of somebody's rights versus
another group's, right? It's not that principally it's it's bad
to get rid of people's rights or or to defend them. It's not
that you like are you're just saying oh yeah well this looks
really bad so I don't want to do it. It's like the same abstract
question. Maybe the block is bigger although it's not probably.
Actually in fact I think it's almost guaranteed the block is
smaller, >> is coming into Democratic Party. Would you
welcome them because they have a D in front of their name instead
of R? He says no. He says no. Hutch what about you? Maybe. Yeah.
There you go. All right. Yeah so that's the difference of opinion
here. I respect him biting the bullet, right? You got to bite
that
You 100% have to bite that bullet if you are willing to bite
the um
if you're willing to take the Ezra Klein approach, right?
Now the argument here is
No you absolutely if you're if you're saying it's important to
get the blue members in Congress because it'll could allow us
to pass things the hypothetical here would have to be that the
segregationist increases your chance of winning like basically
if you want a Democratic segregationist they have to increase
your chance of winning that seat massively. Like you can't win
you can't even compete in that seat without having that position.
You have to bite that bullet if you're going to say we need the
pro-life Dems back. Racism is not the same as being against abortion.
Um no it's not the same, but it is the same you're like you're
signing people's rights away, right? I think. I think it's the
same abstract concept. Obviously the segregationist is worse.
I I I think it's the same abstract
Is Joe Lieberman. Yeah somebody said it was Joe Lieberman.
Uh yes to segregationists. No to them. with obscure tattoos they
got when they were drunk 18 years ago. Yeah, but hold on wouldn't
the argument be that whoever goes against Collins is going to
win?
Right? That's Maine the Susan Collins seat I believe.
That would be the argument there. Yeah. Yeah right. Like I'm
I'm against segregationists no matter what decade it is. Well
do you do you I mean I don't want to get hung up too much. We
can move on to the next topic, but like do you think that Donald
Trump is a
Uh yes. Okay. And Well here's Well how Let me Let me clear right
cuz Hutch you the reason Would you accept a segregationist to
stop a fascist?
Would you accept racism to stop fascism's overtake of the US
government?
Would you do it? I would say yes myself, but go ahead. Okay,
but then tell me if I'm wrong. Guys the reason you would ever
say yes to a pro-segregationist Democrat is because what's on
the other side is now the right has moved so far even past segregation
of yeah we're doing segregation and a lot more worse stuff, right?
Not in I No right now everything the same, but you would welcome
a segregationist Democrat? Wait sorry yeah it is it's required
to say
Yeah it's it's the abstract it's the concept. It's I'm willing
to go against one of my principles because realistically unless
I'm willing to because it's not me going against my principles
it's me accepting someone who goes against my principles. And
holding that principle has no net utility. Holding that principle
only harms me. It has no net utility. A positive net utility
decision is to say I will accept that one person without my principle
because there's no way I could possibly gain any positive utility
into my life into my party into my political system without allowing
that one
Now you'd have to talk about how that goes downstream, but that
is like the
Say that question again. I'm I'm not sure I follow. >> every
policy on the right remains the same. You know I I do think this
is like we're fascist trying to get to fascism, but they haven't
you know they haven't said they're going to bring back segregation
yet. They're teasing the idea of miscegenation you know revisiting
that. >> talking about fascism, right? Like when we talk
about fascism we should get into the specifics, right? What does
that actually look like? >> You're right, but if the Democrats
are pro-segregationists that's worse than the current right-wing
party. You're saying that if if we had like for example like
one Thankfully there are no emerging segregationist Democrats.
I'm happy to entertain your hypothetical, but even if we were
to do this hypothetical
like you're saying that like let's say like one or two like segregationist
Democrats emerge and all of a sudden they were competitive in
like Nebraska or Missouri. You're saying that us adding that
to like get a Senate majority would be worse than the MAGA movement
right now? In terms of like I think it would be I I think it
would make the So if I believed empirically it would help stop
Trump I would encourage you to vote for them, but we just have
a thought process on the empirics. So the empirics are that I
think and I think some people are convinced that allowing segregationists
into the Democratic Party would like hurt mid to long-term results
in the brand of the Democrats such that it would worsen our chances
to I mean Hutch do you guys do you do you guys do you guys understand
that like like black civil rights leaders when they were you
know deciding who they wanted to endorse when FDR was running
they endorsed him even though he opposed an anti-lynching legislation.
And even though a third of the uh Democratic Caucus were segregationists
and Dixiecrats.
because they their concern I think the thing here is you could
say like no in principle and then if we feel like there are specific
specific cases where it could be done and it would be helpful
and it is like the the thing you have to do maybe, but I don't
know you'd probably have to do it. Maybe the the decision here
would be like whose rights are whose rights are being violated?
Maybe we leave that choice to them on supporting this candidate.
concern was fascism was rising.
And yet hold on and yet and yet we have a conversation these
days about like Donald Trump is a fascist threat. And yet like
you I understand Hutch, but this might be a good segue into another
thing we're going to talk about which Primin I talked about last
week which is uh the amount of I I think you and I agree displeasure
and and you know shade thrown at Platner for an tattoo. If he
was a pro-segregationist and was polling better than Susan Collins
would would you not have the same shade thrown? Oh Hutch oh no.
No no no. If Platner advances past his primary I will tell my
viewers to vote for him in Maine. Yeah. This is a This is a primary.
This is a discussion during a primary. That's a Okay. I guess
I guess the idea is in the primary I I doubt that the pro-segregationist
is going to win over any of these other candidates. So the hypothetical
still exists we wouldn't get that far.
Yeah well it is the same logical choice. And it it is a choice
you could say no no no we should never run a like a person there.
I'd say
that the argument on the other side I'm like steelmanning Hutch.
The argument on the other side is like hey I think we need to
probably do like some deeper analysis of how people can beat
us while being like that detached from reality from humanity.
We need to figure out how to message this correctly to people
so they understand so they could process our message and and
hear it in some way cuz like if you've gotten to the point where
America's back to segregation is like actual segregation it's
what what the [__] is happening, man? Like what I don't
know. There's some deeper discussion to be had maybe. Maybe that's
like a how you argue against this, right? And I I was always
talking about it or I tried to talk about like okay
the reason you're entertaining this is because the party's like
disjoint. You don't have a powerful message. If you can get a
powerful message if you can align on something if you force a
paradigm shift of some kind then you don't have to do that. You
don't have to make that choice. Yeah I doubt it. No sorry. But
no this is important to we're we're testing right
his his morals his axioms, right? We're testing that. He's saying
that like yes pro-segregationists are welcome however he defines
that, right? Welcome in the party just because they have a D
in front of their name instead of R in front of their name, right?
Like that's like the essence like it literally doesn't matter
what it is, right? And then he tries to bring in he does he does
exactly what he said. And then he does this copium, right? Like
trying to defend himself like the the nonsense that he just said
in front of everyone here, right? Talking about yeah I mean I
guess the segregationist would be fine, right? And he has to
like bring up like black civil rights, right? Like like people
operating in a different decade, right? Under like a literal
state violence at the time, right? Like looking at a candidate
who they could
work with to overcome that segregation, right? Using the best
political vehicle that they had at the time to >> They made
compromises. Yeah yeah and and and you're saying that within
this decade though, right? Like as it now You brought up segregation.
Yes I obviously
Did you an extreme hypothetical? Hutch what if Yeah but you agreed
to the extreme hypothetical. Yeah you agreed to the hypothetical.
We were talking I I feel like to just agree to the hypothetical
you do have to bite the bullet, but I think it looks bad to bite
the bullet without you have to say like okay like required for
this hypothetical for me to say yes would be that there's a state
where segregation is like on the ballot
and you have to like anybody who refuses to vote for it will
automatically not make it in that state. Will automatically just
not be included
Right? And probably I would say isn't segregation like actually
constitutionally illegal now? Like you you I'm I might say that
it's it's such an absurd hypothetical I don't really want to
entertain it. I don't know. Talking about the hypothetical. And
I'm just I'm thinking about it like you have to explain that
the only way I vote for this is if the like there's
such insane changes and there are states where like we would
lose automatically and it might help us get through something
else. I don't know, man. >> So, it's fine. Soy Soy Boy
did a good job of drawing out drawing drawing this out saying,
"Hey, like >> You're thinking about it too deep? Well,
I'm thinking about it as if I'm uh it's just an exercise
to show how far Hutch is willing to go.
No, it's not an exercise. It's an exercise in like do you believe
in the core concept of what Ezra Klein proposed?
I'm not even thinking about Hutch's position. I'm thinking about
Ezra Klein's. Cuz I don't really find it that useful to think
about Hutch's position. I don't think he thinks that deeply about
it.
I'm very open about like how I work. You're not like You're not
like You don't you didn't like make something out of me. I talked
about this all the time.
You'd say that's fine, right? Even today. Even today. If it meant
Let me just ask you. Like if it meant taking away the Senate
majority from Republicans, would you be okay with it or no? >> No,
I wouldn't No, I wouldn't be okay with segregation. This is just
a Kamala conversation over again. Yeah, I know.
So, this is this is Hutch's point. I don't think Hutch is saying
we should actively encourage Democrats to be segregationists
or we would welcome them with open arms. I think he's just He
thinks he's just repackaging in response to your question a version
didn't say that. I know he didn't say that. I think he's repackaging
an honest a version of the trolley problem where he's saying
like, "I find fascism to be less desirable than Jim Crow segregation."
Well, hold on. It's not like you just It's not like the Democratic
Party takes on the segregation position. It would have to be
something that's legal, that's allowed, right? It would have
to be something that is obviously supported far more on the right
wing, right? To have to be a part of the pro-life
Like you would have to say it's basically what I said where you
would get somebody who's not a segregationist who says they will
vote or abstain vote against or abstain anything like any anti-segregation
bills
while they're running in that seat or something, right? And you
could embrace a politician like that. I don't know. Cuz I To
me it's like
I don't know. It's It's like a mathematical question. I'd like
And I don't even necessarily agree with them. I just think people
aren't really engaging with like
This isn't some massive betrayal of principles on Hutch. It's
like It's testing a different principle than how offensive he
finds segregation. That's probably what I would say at its core.
It's This is not a question of how offensive do you think segregation
is or whatever. That's not really it. It's a It's a question
of an entirely different principle. Do you agree with that, Prime?
Jim Crow segregation, you mean like Dude, Do you agree with that,
Prime? I don't know how that's even different. That's another
If it was just another form of fascism within um
the American society, right? We don't call it fascism, right?
When we're thinking about this, but like like like massive state
violence against that minority. Yeah, that's that's part of a
fascist But I But I think the way you frame it that's what it
is. But it's like, "Hey, as long as there are fascists, right?
According to Hutch. As long as there are fascists, then yeah,
welcome them As long as you have a D in front of it So, let me
let me let me change it slightly, right? Let me let me do it
again. Hey, if they are about fascists, but they have a D in
front of their name, would you welcome them, Hutch? If it gave
us the majority, yeah. Please hold It doesn't matter. You see?
I'M PASSING YOU
I'D SOMETHING GREAT. BUT HERE IS THE DIFFERENCE. The difference
is is by welcoming like one or two people that have extreme positions,
the you the way you framed it, Pisco, was I Also, here's the
other important thing. You'd have to have basically like bulletproof
evidence, like some sort of proof, some sort of statistical evidence.
Not just a feeling, but like some kind of very strong evidence
that this would help, that this would get you a seat, that it
would improve in some
Right? It couldn't just be like, "Oh, well, I have a feeling."
This is why Hutch's Hutch's opinion is has always been, "Oh,
well, we should work with people who are helpful." But then he
kind of arbitrarily decides who will and won't be helpful. Like
he's decided Hassan can't be helpful. Hassan is somebody who
should cut off because Hassan's going to lie, Hassan's going
to work against our goals, all this stuff, right? What you need
is like some kind of proof. You need to be able to show that
that like I I believe I truly
like it's almost empirical that this will be the case. It's not
correct. You were saying like it's either like fascism versus
like Jim Jim Crow. The difference is there would be no risk of
like Jim Crow laws being enacted in the Congress at that time.
And if we allowed like like someone who was like a vowed fascist,
like one person, there would be no risk of like fascist like
codified law as a result of This is an additional thing that
you're saying is assuming it would have a good result, right?
Which I think is the core thing. Assuming that welcoming these
people would produce a less risk Oh, look. It's the smartest
person in the room agreeing with me again. Cool. Thank you. Or
what what what Okay. It's almost like I'm pre-watching this [__]
where the context is different I think back in the '40s and '60s
versus now where that kind of empirical case about whether it
makes sense in the medium and long term to make these kinds of
coalitions where it's Okay. has to break apart. Cherry Cherry
saying that to spite me right now. She's just like, "Oh, you
you Pisco agreed with you. He's over It's over for him." I think
there's a on-point like example of this currently in Virginia,
Jay Jones. Everyone here I think finds the comments made by James
Jay Jones about like >> is that is to say like you do actually
have to uh
You do actually have to know that it will help. If you If you
don't If you like just have a feeling if you want to go in that
direction, it's like kind of goofy to propose this. Which is
again why I think Hutch just leaning into the uh the hypothetical
is very silly.
Oh, I don't know what he said like the deaths of kids.
Yeah. We all find that reprehensible.
I want commitments from everybody. You guys all endorse Jay Jones
for attorney general of Virginia, don't you? Yep.
I'm I'm a little on the fence about it, honestly. Having read
all that stuff. >> On the fence? And why is that? Can I
see these Jay Jones texts?
That Soy Boy's statement here makes me think that
What are the What are the texts from this guy? Are they really
that bad?
I'm not looking. >> thing actually with the Glenn Platner
stuff where I'm like, "Okay, if this is the stuff you're saying
in private, like I don't know how I feel about you being in charge
of a lot, let alone anything." Now, granted, there's not really
a better choice right now. Um but in the same way, you know,
Obama might give Mondani a phone call. I can say, "Look, I'm
not going to be upset if he wins, but damn if I don't want to
put my weight behind him." So, what what objection do you have
against like Prime if Prime's like, "Okay, if this is how Kamala
deals with the the genocide in Israel" um like hang on. So, the
private comments of Jay Jones is enough to be like I might not
vote for him for attorney general of Virginia even if they're
horrible like that? Hold on. The texts were jokes about his opponents.
So, his opponents or kids? Cuz I heard some [__]
about kids,
which was a little concerning, all
All right, hold on.
Jay Jones' dehumanizing text text messages demonstrate his profound
disrespect for the political process and rejection of bipartis
uh bipartisanship. Excuse me, Jesus.
Instead of embracing this solemn occasion where Democrats and
Republicans banded together, Jay Jones fantasized about killing
evil Republican speaker of Virginia House of uh of speaker of
the Virginia House of Delegates.
Sorry, I had I just had some food. My bad. Okay, hold on. They
say nice things about everyone, lol. If those guys die before
me, I will go to their funerals to piss on their graves. Send
them out a washing
Jay Jones. Three people, two bullets. Gilbert and Pol Pot. Gilbert
gets two bullets to the head. Put Gilbert and the crew with the
two worst people you know and he receives both bullets every
time.
Is he talking about Wait, why is he talking about this guy? Cuz
this is actually really funny,
this is actually really funny. I'm
You weren't simply asking questions and you know it. I genuinely
was. I wasn't attacking you. I was trying to understand your
logic. You weren't trying to understand. You were try You were
talking about it and hoping Jennifer Gilbert's children would
die. Yes, I've told you this before. Only when people feel pain
personally do they move on policy. There isn't
I point-blank asked you three or more times or more than three
times and you dug in and meant it. I honestly am questioning
a lot today. I mean, do I think Todd and Jennifer are evil? And
yet that they're bleed breeding little fascists? Yes. Okay, this
guy's This is like too far to talk about the kids. This is This
is frankly like insane.
Who are these Who did these DMs get leaked by? Who did these
DMs get leaked
Wait, this is true. This is a true position, but you should have
the human position of saying, "I don't think people should have
their kids to change their politics." That's That would be the
position here.
Right? That's the human thing. That's what human beings who aren't
total lizards think. But Jesus, like it's just a it's gross thing.
Do we know who leaked these things?
Cuz I'll say there's basically like
partner. This is like There's like his girlfriend. His girlfriend
or his boyfriend could have leaked this. And then I'm like, "Okay,
I'll forgive him a little bit." If he's talking to just like
a friend, if he's talking to a colleague, he's a I wouldn't have
voted for him based on just just him being a total [__]
for putting for putting these opinions on text. Yeah, I'm trying
to look. Does anybody know?
Doesn't seem like anybody knows. To me
I don't know who it was, but the person who leaked it lost her
seat. She was a Republican who lost her seat. Wait, but he was
sent Wait, was he sending this to that Republican who lost her
seat? That's who he was talking to? Okay, it was from somebody
else. Yeah,
I'm asking you about who did he send these texts to?
That's That's the question. That's the only important question
right here.
Anyway, we continue. We continue on with this debate. Sure. And
I guess the difference would be the the scale of the consequences
of him losing. Now, if you were to give me a good case as to
why Jay Jones losing would be detrimental on a massive scale
in in Virginia, I'd say, "Yeah, whatever. I guess we could ignore
this." But again, this is just like welcoming a segregationist
into your While I can completely understand Hutch's like, "Yeah,
obviously if accepting two people who are not going to be, you
know, pass major legislation to stop the fascist party is like
the alternative. Like that makes sense, but what are the downstream
effects of welcoming this into your coalition and like how does
that make you look? Does it reduce turn out? Wait, you don't
you don't think Sorry. You don't think having a Like I almost
feel like segregation is
When segregation is something that like 80% of your country like
abhors, it's constitutionally protected against,
I think it's actually like a really bad example to even entertain
because you'd have to have such a major shift in people's thoughts.
It's like think about the country that you'd have to be in for
the hypothetical to work. And it's like it's just a it's I understand
that like it does still work. You probably bite the bullet if
you believe the Ezra Klein thing, but
that's that's silly. That's not what the then it's it's stupid.
You understand crystallized it's a totally thought experiment,
right?
It's like if I gave you the thought experiment of
What what would be a good version of this? Oh, if I gave you
like the thought experiment of the Aztecs actually kill the Spaniards
and they they technologically advanced past us and actually that's
where civilization blossoms out of is is Latin America instead
of Europe. It's like I can I can give you that, but at some point
that's so different from the way the world is right now that
you can you can like hypothesize, but it's just creative writing.
Like even though I ask you, okay, and then in that world who
do you vote for? It's like oh, well, it's a totally different
world. It does like I I literally can't answer the question.
But now answer the question.
And then when you when somebody points out that the thought experiment
is stupid and lacks any actual purpose in the world, you go,
well, no, I just wanted to know how you thought about Aztecs.
Like is that okay?
A Republican as the attorney general is bad? No, I obviously
You're basically just saying you want to purity test Hatch on
if he'll say segregation bad no matter what.
Which is like okay.
But then just do that.
Don't pretend it's attached to something else. State of Virginia
like that's not I don't The guy apologized for his comments and
text messages between him and a colleague years ago couple years
ago and you're risking getting a Republican attorney general
in one of the most pivotal states in the union, really? Uh it's
not about like I'm risking it. I guess you'd have to kind of
lay out for me again. This is not something I'm super worried
about. I'm >> behind him though? He's the Democrat. Like
the Republican is a thousand times worse. Like I'm not going
to pussyfoot around it at all. It because it's like what am I
willing to say yes, I I will endorse this no matter what and
if the >> You're acting like this is dog catcher. Jay Jones
kind of won because the other guy was pro-life.
Why do you care about a pro-life AG? or in the local community.
This is attorney general of the state of Virginia. It's a huge
deal. >> Sure. So So lay out for me all right, like what
would happen with a Republican attorney general if Jay Jones
were to lose? Well, you wouldn't I understand that they're the
people So the attorney general in the United States decides what
cases to prosecute because they'll prosecute doctors. Oh, well,
sorry, when somebody said that the other guy didn't get voted
for because he was pro-life, I assumed Virginia had some like
super excessive some some like fairly lax like they were a pro-choice
state. Uh how?
He can only prosecute things that are in
This is like a Democratic state. It's like a it's just had a
massive blue wave go through it. It's like totally Democrat in
everything now. You're telling me that you're able to as the
state prosecutor make up laws? Or how does he prosecute plan
B? Stack Supreme Court worries people. This is not the federal
government, right?
This is the state AG. Yeah, I understand that discretion is huge
in how law enforcement manage
but I don't think there's like a lot of discretion on like a
pro-choice state that has pro-choice laws.
See lawsuits on behalf of the state trying to fight for funding
from the Trump administration for example. There could be >> Doing
the government. Mhm. Yeah, like they Go after criminals in the
in in in Virginia in the Commonwealth where like sometimes we
can't count on the federal government to go after criminals and
so we have to rely on like
Wait, this guy Hold on. This guy should be the state attorney
general, right? State Yes, I Correct me if I'm wrong. It's your
guys' political system. The legislature the state legislature
passes state laws. This guy decides how to enforce the state
laws. Now, if you're a pro-life guy, he could prosecute people
who are who are doing like abortion stuff that's on the line
of the laws, but the laws should be like basically non-existent
there. They should be like super open there, right? Just makes
people nervous regardless. Okay. Okay. It's just a vibe. Okay.
That's fine. >> statutes uh to the extent there's overlapping
spheres of jurisdiction. Like some of these Like Alvin Bragg.
Yeah, like Alvin Bragg did. I guess we're in a weird moment where
the ability for the Republicans to paint Democrats as literal
demons to their entire party is kind of unprecedented and so
I'm
Oh, interesting substance. Okay, maybe. Hold on. I asked No,
no, no. I asked what what actual reason there was and a bunch
of people were fighting me in the reason and then now you're
just going to say it's just voters are dumb and it's vibes. Then
I that's fine. Okay, that's
That was like literally my point was it seems kind of dumb to
me. Stuck between 10 years ago Paul Hold on. I literally If you
just want to say they're dumb, that's fine. But I was like it
seems kind of dumb to me and you guys are like, no, it's not
dumb. Like here's all the reasons you wouldn't want one. And
now you guys are going, oh, actually it's just vibes. I'll take
where I look at this and say I don't know how I feel about endorsing
this person and then at the same time, I guess it doesn't really
matter because the worst thing that could possibly, you know,
have downstream effects on us because of some bad comments and
behavior doesn't matter because they already think that. So if
I guess if I was on the fence, I I I lean more towards yeah,
obviously I I I would support, but 100% is a little harder for
me. But Hatch said 80. Can I say 75? Now you sound like Hakeem
Jeffries or Obama with your phone call. Let's flip the Let's
flip the the incentive here, okay? Like would you guys vote for
a segregationist in your state if it meant getting single-payer
health care? Oh. Oh my god. I'm not engaging WITH YOUR SEGREGATIONIST.
WHAT? WAIT, HOLD
UH BAD OPTICS. This is why bad optics hypotheticals you actually
ignore them every time. You say I'm not going to answer that.
Not because I can't answer it. Not because I don't have a belief.
No, I'm just you're trying to clip farm. [__] you.
You. Go on your own stream. Go live. Do your whole dog words
Post that to YouTube. Send it to me so I can use it for blackmail
later and then maybe I'll answer your hypothetical, but probably
not. >> Ridiculous. It's like I'll answer I endorse a serial
murderer if they were the Democratic nominee, you know. Let's
do that. >> Literally a convicted murderer. Would you vote
vote for a
Wait, guys guys, I'm out on the I'm out on this iceberg all alone
this like ice flow and I'm feeling very disconnected. I'm the
only one who bit the bullet on the hypothetical. Guys, just do
any any morally confounding question with me right now right
now, guys, please. Just do any moral confounding question. Morally
confounding question at all. Anything. Pisco, didn't you refuse
to answer whether or not you Hugs, please. Pisco, say something.
Convicted murderer who was pardoned by Donald Trump if it meant
single-payer health care. If you knew for sure that you would
get single-payer health care. And there were no other like mid
to long-term Pisco. Pisco the debate pervert. Okay, immediately
is just like mhm.
Yes. Not to calculate. >> of thing. One Senate vote. It's
just one crucial Senate vote, okay, right? One crucial Senate
vote. So the guy can't like unilaterally go and do a bunch of
But you knew you'd get single payer. He supports serial murder.
Like he's not sorry about it or whatever. Like he's Yeah, he
wants the people he misses on to get health care get healthy
again so he can take another shot. Yeah. He's advocating for
serial I can't believe you guys even have to think about this,
man. It's single
I'm trying to understand your idea. Well, Hatch, I think that
The segregationist would be promoting
Let's get Let's get away Let's just get away from segregation.
It's like playing ball playing ball with like the entire identity
of someone like, hey, every single minority in this country,
we might throw you under the bus potentially or we might get
on the the board to the the road to doing that. We're not doing
it today. We're not doing it a year from now. I said The best
part of this This is a great conversation, but the best part
of this is on the Republican side where like you've got Avi who's
like totally behind Trump. Trump number one. Trump's the best
guy ever when it's only like Mexican people who are having their
lives with who are getting threats of deportation. Now ICE is
like storming cities and arresting random Latino-looking people,
right? And then the second that flips, there's some Republicans
who are like, hey, these people seem to have way too much influence.
Avi's like, this is disgusting. I thought this party had principles.
I thought we had principles. Like no, you didn't. You just You
just were psyched that it wasn't you that was getting targeted.
That's all. You know you didn't have principles. What are you
talking about now? But just so you know, we're going to like,
you know, welcome these people in just for this one thing. It's
a silly hypothetical cuz I don't think like there ever is going
to be this dichotomy in the same >> You're fighting the
Just to say you're fighting the empirical case that he's laying
out in the in the hypothetical. You're fighting the hypothetical.
We both our response is we think that accepting these people
into the in the fold would have negative downstream effects that
aren't so that we would say no. Without those I would say yes.
Without those downstream effects, I do think those exist and
and it's it's reminds me of those stupid AI prompts. Like, oh,
you know, I asked it if a nuke was going to explode or if I screamed
the N-word it would stop. It wouldn't do it. And it's like, yeah,
okay, this is never going to happen. All right, this is very
silly and to get upset I'll Prime here's right now. All You see
just Prime's face when when uh when Soy Pill brings up the Edward
hypothetical, Prime's face just changes like immediately. >> it
would stop. It wouldn't do it. And it's like, yeah, okay,
this is never going to happen.
All right, this is very silly
and to get upset at people for not screaming slurs
You see it, right? You see it. It's kind of ridiculous in the
hypothetical itself because that's not really what's going on.
>> But I'm curious how Prime I'm curious how Prime would
answer given what he asked Hatch. >> I I want to I want
to change it though. I want to change it though. I want to change
it though. Like would you vote for a segregationist if it if
you knew that it would lead to a socialist
Mhm. Who is thinking about it?
one only for white people? Like I don't >> No, for everybody.
Like your ideal socialist revolution >> No, I'm not No,
hold on. I'm saying that there is a minimum of
standard
that I have that for candidates that they have to clear. If they
they're a fascist,
and like Jim Crow was American fascism,
then no, I'm not going to vote for them. Okay, I'm not going
to vote for them. And like Wait, can I can I can I just add a
like a couple more things to it? Like what if what if you had
advanced Would it Dude, Hutch Hutch got left alone on an island
as the only person answering that hypothetical, and he desperately
wants like somebody else to look kind of deranged with him, and
it's just funny cuz it's so transparent. So, I pulled those.
So, I pulled can see what's going on. He knows he's like, "Haha,
nope. You could be out on that ice flow all by yourself." Hutch
is that seal right now, okay? Hold on. This is Hutch right now,
okay? He's about to go to Twitter. Here's all the Here's all
the lefties on Twitter chasing Hutch down, okay? They've got
him out on this ice flow right now.
Where's it at? Where's it at?
It's out there, all right. >> had advanced knowledge that
your socialist friends would murder this man as soon as you did
the socialist
And then everybody gets socialism for minimum 200 years. That's
the bonus is the murder.
We're just doing a nerd problem. We're just doing trolley problems
now. Let's >> think this will be the last hypothetical.
Come on, I just want to know the answer to that question. Like
like no, sorry, no. No, like like what you're trying to do, right,
is like you're saying, "Hey, um like So, the the the hypothetical
that I created, right? I think This is the same thing as like
This is
individual focused harm for diffuse gain, right? Like if you
could make everybody's standard of living going up go up 0.1%
in the US by murdering one person in cold blood, the father of
like four kids, right? It's like, okay. Like that's technically,
you know, utilitarians probably say yes there or something, but
there is some moral transgression happening that you should probably
say no to as well. is firmly
the bounds of like logic, right? Like now we have to bring in
like like exotic technologies, right? So that we can know into
the future what's going TO HAPPEN,
NO, HOLD ON. WAIT A SECOND. NO, HOLD ON. I'LL DEFEND IT. I'll
defend it, right? Because we have a people within our party who
defend genocide. They defend genocide right now. That's the thing
that's happened, right? They defend um
They defend racial hierarchies, right? When they happen in other
places,
and and and and and they continuously within the the current
Democratic Party, they continuously ignore, right, and downgrade,
and exploit the um the >> Oh, Evil Johnny Bravo I said
like 0.1 or 0.01 or something. Like just like you'd have to even
it out a lot to not make it
the black base, right? They come to us hat in hand asking for
our votes, right? But then when when racial violence happens
to us, and we say, "Hey, let's get um let's get a a policy solution,
right?" But like the George Floyd policy or the police get Thank
you. Yes. George Floyd Justice in Policing Act, right? But that
doesn't get passed, right? Like when when the black people who
are a crucial a part of the Democratic coalition, when they
ask for policy solutions, they don't get it, right? Even though
I'm not asking about all that. I'm asking about this like I know
I know I know you I know you want to know about that, but I'm
saying that like like like you are trying
the There's a difference between the hypothetical that I gave
you and the one that you're trying to give me, right? And and
even then, I can even work with your hypothetical. Still no,
right? The answer is still no, right? So, I'll say that, right?
But then I'll go back to criticizing this and say that like like
we're looking at a Democratic Party that has shifted on workers'
rights, abandoned workers. I don't I don't need I don't need
this like Yeah, I don't care. I don't care. I'm I'm not I'm not
talking about You're you're preaching to the choir. I already
gave it. And I I will I will get on my soapbox. I'm going to
actually make my statement. You're going to listen to it, right?
I don't give a [__] about that. So, anyway, um so,
we have a Democratic Party It's just it's funny. has abandoned
the working class, that has abandoned
in their in their conversations LGBT the LGBT crowd. I don't
know if I like agree that that the Dems have abandoned the working
class. I just think there's like a lot of policies that don't
seem to be focused on
working class voters. Or at minimum, I mean, nobody in the working
class seems to think the Dems stand for them. right? Um because
we don't want to be too woke.
that consistently doesn't deliver for a racial minorities, right?
Like this party actually talking about like being okay with segregation,
I don't think that's so crazy. I think there's a point in time
you can No, man. Come on. Come
Well, within with Yeah, I don't Yeah, I don't think it's so crazy.
I think within the the the That the modern Democratic Party would
be advocating for
No, no, no, no. Not the Sorry, not the party, but like there
there were there could be candidates who would actually do that,
right? Like well, Violent candidates? Hold on. Yes, hold on.
With if if it's within a southern state, why not, right, Han?
We have candidates who would not do so, you sure? Yeah, like
there was Indeed indeed we do. Indeed we do,
Hold on. One second. One second. Of course he would. I'm saying
that like within the
the Democratic Party now, right? We
don't have standards. We don't have standards, right? It's it's
what Hutch wants, right? We we have no standards. Within this
party,
you can be anti-abortion, right? You can be anti-LGBT. You can
be anti just about everything. But you guys think that
being anti-black
How many congressional Democrats? How many congressional Democrats
are pro-life in the entire Congress? Hutch, what he's saying
is with the argument that you're advocating for here is and I'm
kind of I'm sympathetic to this is there is no limit to what
a Democrat can believe that violates what we would otherwise
consider a Democratic principle if they help us beat fascism,
which I am sympathetic to in so far as yeah, we need to beat
fascism in the general, but like it's kind of crazy to assume
or or to posit this reality where we just have no like the Democratic
Party ranges from pro-life to pro-segregation, and that's the
only way But then but then it implies that there's a standard,
right? So, is there a standard or not? Because I'm I'm told that
there there is no standard. There should be. There should be.
I mean, but I think it's with respect to different things, right?
So, I think there's a conflation because at the point of general
like I'm just going to go with Hutch. It's really about choosing
the lesser of two evils. And so, at that point like it's got
already cooked, and you just got to do the action I think that
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, we're not No, but but but we're we're we're
talking about something different. There's a anti-black Hang
on. Hang on. Because the thing is I don't want to get your invitation
to absurdity, which is put everything on the table to destruction
of the universe. I mean, Hutch was saying was giving you one
state solution in Palestine, freedom of the Palestinian people.
He was throwing in there Medicare for all. So, that no MATTER
HOW
I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO ENGAGE, BUT THE THING IS BUT I DON'T
WANT BUT I DID ENGAGE WITH IT, RIGHT?
I BUT I AM UNABLE TO bite that bullet. I can't say that I would
suffer the destruction of sentient life on this planet because
to vote for segregation. Like that That to me seems so absurd
and ridiculous that I I could never accept that, right? This
is This is the difference I'm trying to draw with you, right?
So, I can just easily say yes to that, right? Because that's
not a situation that I'm ever concerned about facing, right?
Actually, a pro-segregationist candidate in the Democratic Party,
right? In my lifetime, yeah, that's far more realistic. It's
far more realistic.
I I'm not crazy when I think like the Is it the equal protections
clause that prevents segregation, right? Like is it not It's
It's like constitutional
that segregation's wrong. That segregation's unconstitutional
at this point.
Am I Am I crazy? You think You think somebody's getting like
a constitutional amendment through to allow to reverse the Equal
Protections Act? Stand with the warriors. If we can have an anti
anti-choice candidate, right? Is that a possibility we could
have an anti-choice candidate? Yeah, we have Yes, we have an
anti anti-LGBT
rights candidate, right? We can have
Overturning the 14th Amendment is in Project 2025. Okay, so you're
thinking they what? Get rid of going to repeal the Constitution?
I mean, this is this is what they're going for, yeah. But I'm
It's not really It doesn't seem to be likely right now.
I don't know. Yeah, sure. Depends, right? But can we say black
candidate? Why why wouldn't we have anti Why would that be the
one step that we couldn't cross? Right? Why would that Is that
the standard, right? People just can't be Why not? >> like
when you when you say something like your hypothetical is more
or less realistic, I just like I don't understand like why do
you care that like a hypothetical is more or less realistic.
We're talking about your principles. And the reason we're asking
these questions presumably is to get an understanding of your
principles. And so, how realistic the hypothetical and we're
trying to get at what's motivating you. And so, you commenting
on like, "Okay, I guess I would never have the opportunity to
vote for a segregationist if the other side of the ballot was
literally the destruction of all sentient life." I would I guess
grant you that that's less realistic, but the whole point of
the hypothetical is to suss out like what's motivating you. And
I think it's a good transition into Platner. So, so suppose that
Grand Platner actually was like kind of you know, didn't like
that much, would you vote for him? He said that I think that
He's not with saying the the Okay, at least you're consistent
on that. I'll I'll grant you that. I mean, Yeah. And but but
as I said with Sargon and I, we had that discussion on last week
on Lex
I said that as as of now, as of the recording, right? Other things
can come out, and I would have to have to change my my opinion.
But as of now, it seems like that tattoo is discordant, right?
Like it It's It doesn't match up to everything else we know about
him, right? It seems be
Oh, Primes making my argument on Platner. The tattoo is more
just an like a I don't know sign of judgment. Like he's kind
of a
But anyway, hold on. I need to use the bathroom. I'm going to
hit play. I'm going to keep listening to this Platner part, and
we'll see. I believe Hutch went on to review part of this part
of this after the fact and kind of cope about what was going
on after the fact here. So, I'm going to hit play on this. I
will be right back, probably 90 seconds tops. believable that
he didn't understand what the tattoo was. Um and so, it like
when he didn't think he was being watched, right? His honest
thoughts were he's anti-fascist and a communist and all those
other things, right? Like he said all kinds of wild things. He
didn't say like, as far as I know, again, like I can be corrected.
Um that I I I bought I put the heavens or anything like that,
right? And and so because that the team seems like it doesn't
actually seem to be reflective of his inner personality, well
then
I can I can deal Is it believable to you that he had the tattoo
for like I think 20 years? I don't know when he got it. He's
41 now, I believe. I imagine he was in his 20s when he got it.
Is it believable to you that he never made the connection? I
understand you and I, we don't have that imagery in our life,
but he has it on his chest. He sees it every day and he's more
likely to notice it in a movie or TV or someone else point out
to him. Do you think it's likely that no one pointed out to him
until just recently at 41 years old or whatever it is? Sorry.
Um Do you believe that, Prime? No, no, no. I'm going to answer
your question directly. I'm sorry, I was I was I'm I'm getting
DMs. But I'll I'll I'll to answer you directly, I saw an article
and I can see if I can pull it up again. Um but I I did see an
article that was showing some evidence to say that he was he's
actually lying about that. That like he might have uh known about
it previously just saying, "Oh, I just found out about it. I'm
just covering it up, right?" Um which would be corroborated this
like the former campaign manager had said that he kind of knew
or or knew before that he alluded to and then there was the article
that said he had referred to it as my totenkopf at one point.
Uh which is, you know, that you must know what it is if you use
that name, so. And when Jen Psaki asked him about it, his campaign
manager saying that he said that's inaccurate. He didn't like
push back harshly. But I guess I'm curious, Prime, what are your
thoughts on it after looking at all the evidence and reading
all the articles? Do you think that he honestly didn't know what
that was until just recently?
Um I know. Uh from that the article seemed persuasive as persuasive
to me. And with what you just said, right? Like, hey Um if he
said the line, he definitely knew what it was.
I don't know. He has He has this imagery on his chest. I feel
like there's also there's like a possibility he was told by somebody
in private and he didn't really believe them and didn't think
it was like that important to look up cuz it was just a tattoo.
I don't You would think he would notice it like in like, you
know, a popular media. So no, I think My headphones went all
screwy when I walked away. Give me a second. Sorry, my uh my
headphones didn't reconnect.
They're going. They're going now. Just give it a second. I would
I think this should be good. Yeah, we should be good. >> he's
not being totally honest. I would think he would notice it like
in like, you know, a popular media. So no, I think he's he's
not being totally honest about like when he learned about that.
But you you still support him as the Democratic nominee, right?
You want him to win. You support him still. Yeah, because I've
his policies all in all seem better. I think this is a massive
mistake from I think we I think
when we see these PR nightmares, we see especially a novice politicians,
right? Like handle them badly. All the time we see ex people
in the in the field for like decades like handle it very badly.
So I think he's handling
What was it I would say that um I feel like I should have forgot
what I was going to say. Go ahead. You know, under your version
Don't you feel like if somebody is openly, knowingly getting
and retaining
Is there a decent chance there's a lot of overlap in their mind
with the
I'm just saying that like seems like maybe it's not quite that
I'm just I'm just saying version of events someone knowingly
lied in current day is knowingly lying and maintained a tattoo
a known tattoo Oh, don't do it. Don't do it, you >> for
some period undefined period of time
and didn't cover it up and then and then lied about it. And your
and your response is, well, overall the policy and I agree that
if if we're just doing a cost-benefit like, okay, that's a factor
to consider. But isn't the the likely the the most likely situation
is that he liked the tattoo, correct? And didn't want to get
rid of it. Well, yeah, but Um is that the most
scenario? Well, at the very least at the very least he knew what
it was and he he did a cost-benefit analysis and said, "Well,
if it hurts some other people or it's it's a hateful symbol,
that's that's not my problem, I guess." is kind of what he said.
Now, what if it was like a pro-Israel symbol that he had accidentally
tattooed on his chest? Would you give him a pass on that, too?
Of course I would. Why wouldn't I? Of course I I assume assuming
Wait a minute. Assuming it didn't line up, right? If he wasn't
actual a factual genocidal Zionist. All right, totally thought
he cooked there. All right. He thought he got him. He thought
he got him. He He thought he cooked. He thought he cooked.
If he was a Zionist if he didn't >> if he lied about? What
if he lied about? But what if he lied about, you know, he knew
earlier that it was a pro-Israel associated with pro-Israel?
You'd still give him a pass? >> the then the offense there
is that the politician lied to me, right? Which is what they
do all the time. Certainly Obama did, right? Like um politicians
lie. Certainly Biden did, right? Like politicians lie to their
constituents. I don't like it, right? That's a red flag. Like
I I was saying last week. It's not I'm excusing this thing, "Hey,
don't pay attention to this. Walk away." No, I'm saying integrate
this into your your calculations for whether you want to
Lasting, lasting, lasting. If more comes
No, I'm I am not I'm not dismissing it at all. I don't know what
you're talking about. I'm not saying that at all. I'm saying
Um hey, like um integrated within your your calculations, right?
And if more comes out, it adds to it, right? At some point it
reaches
it's when it's unacceptable. Now, like there's enough outrages
that's unacceptable. You can't vote for them. I'm saying this
outrage, it's an outrage, right? But for me because it doesn't
seem to be enough as far as I can tell, right? Then it is it's
just a bad decision-making on his part. But Prime, given Jump
in real quick. I just want to say cuz the reason this isn't incongruent
with what Prime was just saying is that Prime was saying I won't
vote for someone who is policy-wise pro-segregation, not potentially
a secret segregationist. Now, I'm not saying I'd necessarily
agree with the analysis of the tattoo thing. I'm just saying
that the tattoos are not hypocritical, yeah. I'm not saying it's
a contradiction. I'm not saying that there's a contradiction
yet. But I'm just trying to suss it out. So given your view,
Prime, which is that he knowingly kept it at least for some undisclosed
period of time um why should if it were a swastika, you'd treat
it differently, right?
Yes, because I wouldn't believe that he didn't know what it was.
Okay, that's a Yeah, good point. Right. So given that Right,
but under your lights, right? Under your version of events, he
knew knew that it was a tattoo. So why would you treat it differently
given that So what what what the swastika adds? Well, let me
just say this and then I'll I'll let you talk. I'm sorry, there's
also there's like multiple things going on there where
he could have some idea could be like some loosely affiliated
symbol have like some idea of a connection and not know how close
of a connection it would be. The swastika is like every single
person knows all the time every time you take your shirt off
that you are a like skinhead. Like it's way different if you're
full-on American History X rocking it down the street, okay?
That's that's so different. It's so it's just entirely different
universes.
That's all. But what the swastika adds is no one can reasonably
believe he wasn't aware that it was a tattoo cuz the swastika
is a known tattoo. But given that you think he knew at at least
some point that it was a tattoo, doesn't that equalize them?
No, it doesn't at all. Not at all, right? Because if he got the
the tattoo way back when, right?
There's a there's even a difference between like he kind of had
some beliefs he wanted it coded cuz he understood it was like
socially transgressive. He wasn't hanging around a bunch of all
the time. Right? Cuz if you had got a if you got a swastika tattoo,
you've suddenly narrowed down all of your social connections,
anybody you're willing to go to the beach with, right? Like there
are just some practical considerations there that it's like I
I'm sorry, there's like so much more wrong with the swastika
the full-on
Like obviously a lot of the associated beliefs are really bad.
I'm just saying that like
this guy you can't convince me he changed his mind if it's a
swastika. That's the difference.
You could maybe convince me he changed his mind with just the
totenkopf the skull. The swastika is like, "No, I'm pretty sure
that guy's a I'm I'm not really ever going to let it
Like that's this way different. Um that means he that almost
certainly means
Right? It pretty much 99% means he's even though he never said
it, right? Like there's no way to believe that he didn't understand
what that symbol was and he put it on his body, right? And so
I would say he's actually a secret tosser, right? But for if
he made a >> Oh, I see. in the past, right? And found out
later, but simply didn't rectify that immediately or he lied
about it.
Uh your Sherry says she's more concerned that the military didn't
know and let it pass. I'm pretty concerned that the military
did know and let it pass. Which I feel like is more concerning
to me. Oh, it's not explicitly against the rules. Fair enough.
What I'm understanding is at the point of application of tattoo
Wait, are all tattoos against the rules or are like specifically
like political or hateful symbols against the rules? I actually
don't know. Two that there's no
hate symbols. Yeah, hate symbols. doubt as to for the swastika,
but there could be at the point of application for the the tattoo
he has. And now explaining why he didn't get rid of it is maybe
easier to do than why he put in the first place. That would have
Um yes. Well, what is the what is the response about why he didn't
get rid of it instantly? Yeah, but the once you once someone
tells you, "Hey, that's an tattoo." and you're like, "Yes, it
is." then you're accepting that you have an tattoo on you, which
could have happened years ago. That's it's a bad thing. >> "I
have got an tattoo on me. Oh, well, I guess I mean I would be
horrified if I had some sort of big tattoo on me. I would agree.
Me, too. Like I don't know. I'm not saying it's a good thing.
What's the explanation that like he like he just didn't care
that he had an tattoo or that he it wasn't a top of his priority
to get rid of it? What is the explanation? The explanation is
I don't know the explanation.
Okay. I think we've probably made it through a lot of this with
the Platner stuff. Um We can maybe come back to this. I I'll
go ahead and save the timestamp in case we do want to come back
to it in case we got time. Guys, I should shill right now. I
think we've got what, 45 minutes left on the stream or so. About
45, yeah. And we are
10 subs from another 2 hours on the stream, all right? 10 subs,
$50. You can you can provide, you know, you can sub. You can
sub individually. You can give subs. You can sub on Twitch. You
can sub on Kick. You can donate through the TTS platform Streamlabs
through Kickbot. All right? Every dollar goes to more time on
the stream.
All right. And if we don't make this this goal right now, we'll
probably go do either the Aerodite stuff or possibly
some like Pixie court case content review in the Orlac call.
All right. Or probably in a supporter call here. We'll see. I
need to figure out new benefits to give oilers, but I think probably
we'll do a supporter call. Uh if we don't hit the 6 hours, we'll
go do it in there. Okay? Or sorry, if we don't hit the 8-hour
mark. If we just if we end in 45.
Oh, why did I hit play on this? Whoops. I'm going to go watch
this we can move from here to the Hutch cope on his own stream,
okay? Hutch had
his own stream the next day.
He went reviewed some of the Prime Kai stuff, okay? Let's check
it out. I had a conversation last night on the street on the
podcast where I may or may not
have expressed
an openness
to coalition building with
segregationists. And I know how that sounds. I get it. I may
or may not have No, you definitely did.
Uh you definitely did.
I get it. Doesn't sound great out in
Hold on.
We got a donation. What is that? That's Private Hoff with the
five gifted. We're five gifts away, $25 from another 2 hours
in the stream. Let's go.
But a lot of you guys don't tune into the podcast. And so um
you don't see a lot of these conversations.
And uh I I think this conversation
kind of directly relates to what we just watched from Ezra. So,
I think it is informative and helps to expand on the idea.
I miss one stream and you go crazy. Now, it sounds bad. But I
promise you it'll all make sense. And so
we're going to tune into this a little bit. I want to get your
guys thoughts. How did y'all manage to force out EconoBoy and
Josiah?
That was not that was not my doing. I still
regularly have conversations with EconoBoy by the way.
But not Josiah. Curious.
I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not going to actually do this to Hutch,
okay? What's wrong What did Hutch do to Josiah? Why is Why I'm
just that's I'm pretty sure Hutch and Josiah still talk, okay?
Even though he said it that way.
We're still I don't know for sure though. Like we still text
like a a lot. Oh, she's like not friends with He says he's just
The way he said this is so funny that you could just you could
infer, but it's So. Same with Josiah. Okay, he saved it. Uh you
do be walking into Destiny-esque hot water with wacky statements
like that. Never forget people don't understand context or nuance.
Here's my Here's my position. What I said was not wacky at all.
At all. Uh don't you kind of think you're doing something like
Destiny did where he'd like do something controversial?
And Hutch is like No, I'm not doing something like Destiny did
by being controversial. I'm going to just double down on some
inflammatory statement immediately. And like yeah, I I'm going
to just double down on that, okay?
>> think what I Thank god we're not on Twitch right now.
That's all I say.
>> And we'll get into that more. Again, I just want to
show you guys the clip and then get your guys thoughts and we
can kind of go from there.
Is this when we start talking about it? allergic to that kind
of power. You know what I mean? Like you're you're kind of like
pushing that away.
Okay, hold on. Let's back up a little bit. So, he's talking about
Mumdani Hocal all that whole thing. It's like he, you know, earlier
in the conversation he was talking about um
Kathy Hochul doing a speech at the Mumdani rally. And he was
framing it like haha, she's going to bend the knee or she bent
the knee. Um very hostile. Like he's very hostile kind of
that we're dealing with these days. Uh Space Limes, thank you
so much for the uh gifted sub, buddy. Put this behind but he's
not actually doing that. You're saying he had a conversation.
Great.
Uh uh this was me talking about Obama called Mumdani to like
congratulate him and tell him he ran a great campaign, but it
wasn't enough for Prime for Prime, right?
Guys, I know it sounds
like I may have endorsed coalition building with segregationists.
But I have to show you how annoying this black guy was that pushed
me to that position, okay? Look at what he had to say about Obama.
What am I supposed to do, right? Am I supposed to go It was a
It was a It was a private conversation where Obama relayed that
he was he found Mumdani's
It's a bad faith interpretation on my part, okay? It's a joke.
>> pain to be I don't think Hutch believes that. inspiring.
It's not an explicit public endorsement, but you know, that's
not nothing.
I feel like well just real quick, let me
I feel like Well, hold on. Let me Let me Let Hutch finish real
quick. I feel like someone in your position should not be so
like allergic to that kind of power. You know what I mean? Like
you're you're kind of like pushing that away.
You're you're taking this like actively hostile kind of position
when it comes to Hochul and Obama. But this is, you know, this
is a guy that's a democratic socialist poised to become the mayor
of the most populous city in the country. And so and he's getting
support from these like unlikely figures. And you're
That's not support.
Well, getting support from Hochul and
Jeffries is pretty pretty unlikely. Like that's that's kind of
a new thing.
You know, this is
That's pretty significant, man. Does Hutch not understand
why that happens? Like what's going on?
You can act like it's a new thing.
How new of a thing is it for a lifelong Democrat to lose a democratic
primary and then run independent against
How normal is that, right? With the support of like a ton of
people by the way. Like a ton of people. Not necessarily elected
democratic officials, but with the support of a ton of donors,
of a ton of people who usually support Democrats, right? And
then of Republicans openly.
That's pretty different, too. Almost like it was a totally unique
situation that required a unique response.
To the To talk about the historical precedents, right? Doesn't
really make a lot of sense. And the how the house minority leader
uh in That's why I said lifelong Democrat. Yeah, actual Democrat,
actual elected Democrats telling us laugh. Yes. >> endorse
a democratic socialist to be mayor in New York City. That should
be in my opinion. Did she take this from Twitter or did she just
come up with it? Actually, if you think about it, Cuomo is the
most American person right now. He lost a job opportunity to
an immigrant Indian twice. Immigrant Ugandan.
Not Indian, okay? Wait, or are his parents like ethnically Indian
or
I've been thinking about Mumdani being Indian for a while right
now. His parents were Oh, both of his parents are Indian. Okay,
they're ethnically Indian. Okay, they just moved to Uganda. All
right, fair enough.
Andrew Cuomo's about to come out
make his next guest appearance on the Nick Fuentes podcast, okay?
Talk about how H-1Bs got to go. That should be
something that's welcomed from progressives. They should see
that as like oh, okay, that's like that's movement in a direction
that we've been asking for for a really long time. But when it
happens, it's treated antagonistically.
Uh you missed some subs back in Twitch chat.
I don't think I did. Space Limes, uh I didn't miss that. Space
Limes, wait, no. No, I didn't. What are you What are you talking
about? Uh thank you for the gifted sub, buddy. I'm pretty sure
I did not miss that. I could be wrong.
Wait, Prime Prime. I think the the idea is yes, Obama didn't
come out and be like I'm fully behind Mumdani, which would be
ideal obviously from that person in power. But for most mayoral
races, if not all of them, Obama is not involved whatsoever.
And by putting his name next to it, I'm going from the Democratic
Party. Yeah, I know. Well, I I think yeah, now that I'm thinking
about it, Prime could have easily just argued this is a totally
unique case. What do you think of a major like a major participant,
somebody with actual pull in the Democratic Party for a long
time, Andrew Cuomo, losing the democratic primary and then running
independent trying to scuff trying to rap the party, okay? What
do you think about that? Do you think that required a bit of
a unique response from some of the members, some of the lifetime
or sorry, lifelong members of the Democratic Party as well? That
one of their peers was stabbing the party in the back. I just
think that it's it's it's the very least above a positive or
above a neutral, excuse me, which is positive because you now
have headlines of Obama attached to Mumdani. It's not as far
as you'd like it to go, but it is helpful I I think to it. >> Yes,
just like Obamacare, right? I mean, it's something, right? Not
as far as you'd like it to go, barely useful. But like I mean,
it's something, right? And so we give Obama a pass, right? Hey,
he called, right? And and so I I guess
My face
re-listening to it is the same just organically. I just started
making the same face that I made in the moment.
should sing his praises. Look, Obama who has spent his time,
right? Outside of office doing Netflix documentaries, right?
Like pretending to be above it all as the country burned around
him, right? He's he's finally decided to step out and and talk
to someone. I feel like What am I expected to do with this? I
I feel like people I feel like people with your attitude lend
credence to the idea that the establishment should pivot to the
center instead of trying to work with you guys. Cuz Okay, that's
not whatever. Yes, I don't get I don't get a [__]
You're not exactly You're not exactly incentivizing like a friendly
coalition, are you? I don't I don't care. Well, what are you
What's your goal? Um I don't Oh, hold on. My goal is to uh increase
human flourishing, right? And I think to do that would require
left leftist positions. But it would require power, right? It
certainly does require power, but that doesn't require
I Hutch is going to have to talk more for me to be interested
in this. >> It certainly doesn't require groveling.
It certainly doesn't require
someone getting amnesia. It doesn't
getting amnesia about like the past 20 years, right? I'm like
miss like misremembering
the Obama years and misremembering his post-presidency
and all of a sudden being ecstatic that he gave a phone call.
It's really funny because I feel like a lot of left-wing politics
in America is
driven by
What did he say? Misremembering?
Or mischaracterizing
the Obama years. That's like a big part of
his politics. Like his kind of politics. Actually, no one's asking
you. There's an actual constitutional weight behind it. Wait,
yeah, but no one's No no one's asking you to be like, oh, you
know, thank you thank you God King Obama for, you know, taking
10 minutes out of your day. It's more of just like acknowledging
like, oh, this is good for Mondani. He's getting, you know, former
presidential recognition. This will catapult him into a a a higher
tier. It's not like, you know, the difference between winning
or losing and an endorsement would obviously be more desired.
No one's asking you to say thank you to Obama. It's just But
they have This is a good thing. Well, then okay, fine. Then I
can give you this. If that's all you're asking, right? Well,
here's what I'll do, right?
As you as I soy said previously or maybe it was Pizzicato.
Whether this is, you know, on the scale of bad, neutral, or positive,
right? It's slightly past neutral into positive. Hooray. I thank
you for more crumbs, President Obama. I want to get to something
I mean probably a little bit halfway, which is there have been
legitimate criticisms, I think of Obama's
post electoral victory
behavior, including him dropping off the map after his first
election win and not really doing anything with the the grassroots
coalitions that he had built from an electoral perspective.
Hey, hold on. Apparently this is the good part of Give me a second.
I'm going to back it up just a little bit. You know what I mean?
Like Give those nukes and this military to a fascist. What would
that have looked
So anyways, I don't know. I feel I feel like the word fascist
means something different maybe to to people like Prime. Like
I don't what he thinks that word means or I don't know what fascism
means to him. Um When I say that word, I'm I'm being
And I've gone into more detail about Why is he reacting? He's
reacting because he doesn't like that people are saying that
he supports segregation now. This? Because I don't think that
the current moment that we're in right now represents an immediate
of a full-on fascist
um takeover.
I view the moment right now
Interesting. But I I did think this is a his opinion, by the
way. Do you remember how I told you that like I think he he doesn't
see it as like that big a thing. He thinks it's going to pass
and swing the pendulum's going to swing back.
Which is why the argument with Prime was going weird cuz this
is actually his true opinion. As the sort of potential
sort of early stages
Donald Trump, quite frankly, is just not that guy. He is too
incompetent, too
incoherent, too diminished. There's people that are speculating
that he had a stroke recently and that's why he's getting MRIs
and he's just like when you listen to him speak I would say he
may be diminished. It sure seems like the party's been very effective
in getting exactly what it wants done and he's acting asking
for these barriers to be broken. He just put a total stooge USA
uh Oh, is it US attorney, right? He's put a total stooge attorney
in in Virginia to prosecute Comey and Letitia James.
Right? Like I don't know. It's it seems like he's going It seems
like there's actual fascism happening.
I'm pretty sure once you start actually getting your like totally
transparently
uh engaging in political prosecutions, I feel like that's got
to be like you're in. You've entered the window, right?
He is diminished.
He's He's going down.
Um He just doesn't have the popularity,
the competence, and I think even more importantly, his cabinet
is incompetent. Say what you will about
No good sentence ever started with those
But he had competent people around him that good sentence ever
started Say what you will about him.
No good sentence ever started with those
But he had competent You can say use anyway. I love that he's
like, I shouldn't be doing this, but I'm going to do it anyway.
10 people around him that were able to to, you know, execute
on his fascist vision,
Um All Elite Memes with $5. Fascism is the opposite of
liberalism. Lefties aren't liberals, so they don't care. Hassan
It's not devalued. They just never
It Well,
I think it is devalued. I don't know I don't know if that's
I don't know if that's um
intentional on their part on their part to devalue like the the
word fascism.
But that's what's happening at least as far as I'm concerned
because I just don't see the same urgency. It's just not It doesn't
It doesn't seem like an urgent threat.
Um I really doubt Prime endorsed Kamala.
In 20
That might That That could be true, but like Why Why does he
always do this? He always does this. He just like makes the
He just makes the assumption instead of asking. Like maybe one
of your chatters watches. Or just asking the person.
I doubt this guy did this 2024. Like I'm just going to guess
that he didn't because of the uh Israel stuff. I searched for
vote
on his feed.
Okay, hold on. What about Kamala?
Nope. He does not tweet a lot, so I assume he did not endorse
Kamala. And that he did not he did not vote for
So as soon as somebody tells me that,
I don't think that person really understands the urgency of the
threat of fascism. Which is It doesn't It doesn't make any sense
to me. How could How could you? How could you really I could
be wrong. Listen. I Yeah, I am I am assuming that, yeah.
Wait, yeah, I had a conversation with I was on a WIC panel with
him and he said he wasn't voting for Kamala because of like genocide
or whatever, right?
That was my understanding of why he wouldn't be voting for Kamala
was the didn't like the or or not endorsing Kamala or
There's something about the the genocide, yeah. I'm not making
that up.
Right? Like if instead we had a the whole list of Democrats that
you won
who were like pro-segregationists, you'd Is this for Kyle? Yeah,
Kyle didn't appreciate it. I believe that's why Kyle's blocked
him. They like what I I welcome them within the party. Right?
They They have a D in front of their name not an R. And so thank
you Please, let's fill up with pro-segregationists. You're welcome
here. I mean, we'd be going back to the Democratic Party of,
you know, five or six decades ago, >> Sorry, that didn't
answer my question. Would you welcome >> is probably yes,
yeah. I thought that did answer the question, but >> That
context that wouldn't you rather have the I mean, to be clear,
when I say like welcome, like I wouldn't celebrate. Like I would
look at if if if there was a constituency in a particular district
dis- district
of,
you know, Democratic primary voters
would for whatever reason elevate a segregationist to be their
candidate,
I wouldn't be like, yeah, that's great.
I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily celebrate it. However, dot
dot dot. the New Deal and the Great Society stuff then The way
this guy speaks is such a meme. Jesus Christ.
Not? Sorry, one second. One second. Stop trying to dodge the
question and you >> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
>> I'm not No, hold on. No, it's not We're not time traveling
cuz he now he's like, oh, now we're going back in time. No, we're
not doing that. I'm saying, hey, like We're not time traveling,
but also here entertain a hypothetical where you know, segregationists
end up winning Democratic primaries. Okay. Right? 2025.
Right? Or 20 into 2026. We have new brand new pro-segregationists
coming into the Democratic Party. Would you welcome them because
they have a D in front of their name instead of an R. He says
no. Pizzicato says no. Hutch, what about you? Maybe. Yeah. There
you go. All right? Yeah, so that's a difference of opinion here,
right? Like I'm against segregationists no matter what He really
thought he had a gotcha here. He did. >> Well, do you do
you I mean, I don't want I mean, you didn't ask any questions.
It just seemed like you
Uh I get hung up too much. We can move on to the next topic.
But like do you think that Donald Trump is a fascist?
Uh yeah. Oh, wait. What? Hold on. Okay. Oh, he's moving away
from the Ezra Klein thing. This is the issue here, okay? This
is no longer the Ezra Klein thing. I think we're five subs away,
Rile, by the way. I thought I saw you ask this earlier. But we're
moving away from the Ezra Klein thing here, are we not? A little
bit? I You don't have to do this. You don't have to say Donald
Trump's a fascist this way because unfortunately Hutch is is
running into, you know,
a thing I guess we we call it time, the the construct of time.
So, back here, which is happening now, he's replaying it, but
Hutch back here is using Donald Trump's a fascist, right? While
Hutch right here has just finished telling us how he doesn't
think Donald Trump is really a fascist. He's like too incompetent
to enable fascism.
And so, if his if his excuse is going to be, hey, back here,
past Hutch is going to say, well, do you think Donald Trump's
a fascist? Then shouldn't you to avoid fascism like vote for
a
But then he in future says, but I don't believe the next day,
I don't believe Donald Trump's a fascist. I don't believe he's
going to be able to enable fascism. Then why is Hutch answering
yes to the hypothetical of would you allow a segregationist in
the party that meant averting Donald Trump, right?
Am I wrong?
Is he not totally [__] himself up? Like taking both
positions?
Well, here's the Well, Hutch, let me let me clear it up, all
right? Cuz Hutch, he
I love Soy Pill. I'm going to do the Pisco. I love Soy Pill.
He's Ah, he's my
He keeps jumping in and trying to trying to save Prime. Wait,
the reason you would say yes is to save yourself, but go ahead.
Can I repeat that? So, Hutch in this is about to try to say,
well, here, Prime, do you do you agree with me that like Donald
Trump's a fascist and fascism's on the rise and we have to stop
fascism? And he's hoping that Prime will say, yeah. He's like,
well, I'm willing to allow one segregationist into the Democratic
Party in order to accomplish like the aversion of fascism.
But then here in the future, Hutch down here, future Hutch, current
Hutch, is saying, well, actually, I don't really think Donald
Trump's a fascist. I don't think he's like too incompetent. I
don't think he can get anything done. So, he's sort of undone
the hypothetical that he said yes to. He said yes, and now the
reasoning he's using to try to convince Prime is actually working
against what he said just the next day.
Which is just leading me to believe like Hutch doesn't really
got a lot of principle here. Okay, but this is my argument. The
reason you would ever say yes to a pro-segregationist Democrat
is because what's on the Would Hutch team up with gropers to
secure more Democrat
I feel like he'd say no to that, but not along any logical grounds,
right? He would say He would say no to that because he doesn't
want to be associated. That's it. I think he would say that according
to Prime's own assessment of Trump that his position is incoherent
because if he really thought he was a fascist, he'd be open to
defeating him by any means necessary, including allowing segregationists.
Yeah, that's also true. Could be just could just be an internal
critique for Prime's position, yeah. The other side is now the
right has moved so far even past segregation of yeah, we're doing
segregation and a lot more worse stuff, right? Not in I Oh, right
now. Everything the same, but you would welcome a segregationist
Democrat?
Say that question again. I'm I'm not >> Right now, every
policy on the right remains the same. You know, I I do think
this is like we're fascist trending to fascism, but they haven't,
you know, they haven't said they're going to bring back segregation.
Yeah, they're teasing the idea of miscegenation, you know, revisiting
that. >> talking about fascism, right? Like when we talk
about fascism, we should get into the specifics, right? And what
does that actually look like? >> Well, right, but if the
Democrats are pro-segregationist, that's worse than the current
right-wing party. You're saying that if if we had like, for example,
like one Thankfully, there are no emerging segregationist Democrats.
So, I'm happy to entertain your hypothetical, but even if we
were to do this hypothetical,
like you're saying that like, let's say like one or two like
segregationist Democrats emerge and all of a sudden they were
competitive in like [__] Nebraska or Missouri, you're
saying that us adding that to like get a Senate majority would
be worse than the MAGA movement right now? In terms of like what
the >> I think it would make the the So, if I believed
empirically it would help stop Trump, I would encourage you to
vote for them, but we just have a different
uh thought process on the empirics. So, the empirics are that
I think and I think Soy Pill is convinced that allowing segregationists
into the Democratic Party would uh like hurt mid to long-term
results in the brand of the Democrats such that it would It's
not ideal, just to be clear. Like if two hypothetical segregationists
emerge and then one seats in the Congress with a Democratic Party
label, obviously that would not be ideal in any sense. We're
not
Why was Hutch getting so much when Pisco is saying yes?
Uh because Pisco is saying it the way that you should be saying
it. It's like, listen, there's probably some universe where you
should convince where you can convince me of that, but it would
have to be a universe where you can convince me that my principle
against segregation, against like racial discrimination, being
violated is being is I'm violating that principle in service
of preventing a worse outcome, and you'd have to very strongly
convince me of that. And now you have it you haven't done that.
You're just giving me the hypothetical, so I'm going to say no
because until you can convince me all the way, give me the context
that convinces me, then it's like a no. To avert what we have
right now? No. So, is it possible? Yes, but like you'd have to
give me way more in the hypothetical. If all else equal, there's
just a segregationist could help us stop Trump right now? No,
[__] that.
Seems pretty obvious. We're not really having a conversation
about ideal. In fact, we're This is me trying to have a conversation
moving away from idealism and more into just the current reality
of the current moment that we're in and the potential outcomes
that we're in and the potential outcomes if the conservative
MAGA movement continues to grow and flourish, like what does
that future look like? And when you think about that potential
future in your mind and you imagine the potential consequences
of that, what would you be willing to compromise in order to
Hasn't Trump kind of proven that embracing that kind of radical
in your party, assuming that the person is charismatic enough,
can kind of [__] your whole party? No, no, not the
way like a senator would. The issue with Trump is not even that
he's charismatic and radical. Those could be fine. He'd have
to If he was honestly arguing his
in any way, if he wasn't just basically
borderline like neurolinguistic programming stuff to essentially
lie and have people not call him out, that it would it would
be like it probably be fine. It wouldn't get as much play, right?
But the fact is he he like does all of these signaling, all of
the coded stuff to make it seem like he's right in moments where
he's just lying, and the people who can actually see what's happening
are willing to go, well, you know,
it is what it is. I hate the Democrats. Right? And they they
just they embrace this party of like where the the truth means
nothing. That's the problem they have, right? That the truth
of the matter doesn't doesn't it doesn't factor in. It's just
whoever can tell the best story, whoever can convince people.
Truth literally doesn't matter at all.
That's why Fuentes is winning. It's why he's probably going to
continue winning for the foreseeable future. They'll have to
start engaging with the truth again, start grounding themselves
in like the in the truth in fact in some way for to stop this
from happening. Otherwise, the most charismatic, funny, best
storyteller is going to win. Unlucky. to make sure that that
didn't happen. And I promise you, that's not Mark Levin, okay?
That is not Mark Levin. That's not Ben Shapiro. It's not any
of those guys. That's what it comes down to. Worse than our chances
to
Do you guys Do you guys understand that like So, Yappasaurus
Rex, you can you can allow people to have a segregationist belief,
but then they'd have to give you like facts, reasons why they
believe that, right?
And and when they're I guess when they're confronted with counterarguments,
they can't just wipe away sweep away those counterarguments without
responding. They'd have to engage with like facts, have a conversation,
and agree to like what the pros and cons of each side are. And
to some extent that was politics pol- politicians could still
do that in a lot of ways even 20 years ago, even 10 years ago
to some extent. And now we're at the point where it just like
straight up doesn't happen. Can't happen at all. So, like black
civil rights leaders when they were, you know, deciding they
wanted to endorse when FDR was running, they endorsed him even
though he opposed an anti-lynching
legislation. And even though a third of the Democratic Caucus
Okay, I'm probably good with um